The Joe Rogan experience,
the next evolution of the podcast is
complete.
Ladies and gentlemen.
It feels like a fucking radio station
now.
We got real chairs instead of those
goofy couches.
We got rid of that shit.
One of them's at our house.
The other one's in Brian's place.
What'd you,
what'd you,
by the way?
Uh,
he,
uh,
I think he wants it now.
So now I'm like,
Oh,
I want your chair.
Yeah.
Why?
Because he has said so.
What'd you do last night?
I went over to Joe's.
Help them hook up the studio and he was.
Oh yeah.
Well I think I made to get to that.
Sure.
Because you can't even fit that chair
anywhere in your house.
I was thinking about doing something
like Joe did pretty much taking out my
whole and my office is just fucking
scary.
I can't even go in my office just too
much shit.
So I think I need to empty the whole
thing out.
Redo it and Redo it from scratch.
Yeah.
I still need to Redo this area back
here.
By the way,
bitches were sponsored by the fleshlight
holiday boys.
A fleshlight that com,
if you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click the link,
you will get 15 percent off so you get a
discount on your masturbation and
whatever the fuck it's costs what it's
50 bucks or 60 bucks or 100 bucks.
It's worth it.
Because think about what a hooker costs
and you could shoot mad loads with this
thing.
I don't know though,
if you've been watching cops that,
some of these hookers,
like $10.
I mean they,
they look like $10 hookers,
but it's still.
Think you want to get a $10 hooker ever
in life.
And Allison,
now speaking to $10,
what did he say?
How rude.
Uh,
we're,
we're here with Alison was alison,
I don't even know your last name.
Allison.
Shula.
Shula,
Allison.
Shula.
I know her as Allison Brock's from
twitter,
r o x.
and she's Brian's friend and she's a,
a young and upcoming standup comedian
doing the fucking Hollywood shuffle out
here,
making it happen.
Making it real.
She's a cool chick and she rides
motorcycles.
She's fucking crazy.
She's a [inaudible].
She's,
she's been brought into this world of
slapped Brian into,
in place before we get started with
anything entertaining.
Um,
uh,
this weekend Ari and I are going to be
at the West Palm Beach Improv.
I'd see a 28th,
29th,
and 30th and Brian's gonna be there too.
We're going to have a big,
big party.
And if you don't get mad at Brian,
if he's behind you making faces while
you're taking pictures with me,
he'd done that.
He did stop doing it.
But really you had done it for six
years.
Yeah,
six plus years and maybe taking a
hundred and 50,000
pictures.
You've really for real.
Might've taken $150,000
if not more than that.
Think about all the UFC is all the
comedy shows for six years over and over
and over again.
Hundreds of people in night.
Crazy buffets.
If you have any of these pictures,
where can people send them?
We should create a gmail.
Wait,
we had one on my space for awhile.
Until you did.
You ended up deleting it?
No,
I can't.
I try to delete it.
We'll let these fucks.
My plates are so tricky.
Like yeah,
we'll get back to you with an email.
It's like a girl that you could never
break up with.
I'll call you back and then we'll break
up the pitch.
Never called you back.
You guys should make a tab on your
webpage.
So just has those photos.
Like a photo gallery.
We.
Yeah,
we should totally know.
They're hilarious dude.
It's,
you know what's not funny?
Three of them.
You know what's funny?
300,000
dollars.
That's when it gets funny.
If becomes hilarious because it was
just,
you just fucking committed to that shit
for so long.
Like I would be like,
this guy's a monster.
He's fucking.
People give up on shit.
They have a silly idea and,
and they give up on it.
Brian will fucking ride that boat right
into the ground.
It's the beach.
He still in the boat.
Boom.
And has to hit the rocks for he stops
and he,
he's a,
he's a determined little fella.
Gets crazy ideas.
And he said,
well that's why videos are so good.
Because if they,
if he wasn't so determined,
he wouldn't keep going,
you know,
he has like all this cool footage and he
puts it together,
but that's not enough.
You know,
he always has to add like a million
different things and sound tweaks and
very under appreciated.
It's like drive both motivation.
It's like really nice when you meet
people like that and we're going to
figure out a way to make money off your
fucking video skills do because you look
at other people's videos online.
I look at your videos,
dude,
you got some fucking mad talent when it
was a video.
A big problem though,
is that when,
when I do it,
I do so many layers and so many little
things that no one will ever know.
Notice,
you know,
it's just like in my head like crazy
person.
Like if I were to ever do that,
like do notice.
Yeah.
There's.
So there's a,
there's a artistic quality to these
videos.
It's fun and it makes it,
it's an extra layer.
It's like,
it's like the nuttiness and when you're
sipping wine taste.
I tasted oak,
it squeezes the last brain juice out of
my brain though and after I do one it
is,
I just want to fucking cry.
You don't want to do a long time.
I've been with Brian on both times of
where he's kicked the power to was
computer and losses project because the
whole thing shuts down because my
fucking office sucks because you've got
numb feet,
motherfucker.
You're walking.
Well you what?
Yours is exit pretty good.
But like underneath my desk it's just
every single wire and the power cord
like this is updated.
This is updated.
That's one of the reasons why I wanted
to get those cord ties.
We got caught,
we redid the whole thing.
You don't give a fuck because you're
just listening,
most of you.
But uh,
we for the longest time I just figured,
well I'll make it look like a living
room and we'll sit around and so I got
couches but couches fucking suck.
You know,
like if you're sitting up and you're
trying to talk to people like these are
comfortable way better.
This is way better.
So we've got office chairs and we got a
circular snort cocaine off this table.
If you want to do that,
dude,
you should start bad habits.
Been living my life.
Good too long.
Start talking.
Start fucking up.
You don't know about them because they
kind of want to be like,
yeah,
you know what I think we're going to
have to do.
We're going to have to get those ones
that you have like on the radio,
like when you go to open anthony and I
have like an arm to arm.
Yeah,
we've got to get an arm.
I have those at my house.
They always break,
but I think I got cheap ones so maybe
they make better ones.
We've just got to talk to someone when
we do radio in West Palm,
we'll find out where they buy their
arms.
Can't wait.
Look it up.
It's going to be fucking crazy.
So please tell me what you were telling
me before we started the podcast.
What made you stop?
Because it was so ridiculous.
We had to talk about this in the air.
Oh,
John Travolta is starring in the new God
movie.
He plays John Gotti ads as the lead
roll.
Okay.
Listen,
this had to have been a plot by the
government.
If what?
God is dead right.
He died in prison,
didn't.
Yeah,
I was saying they're just trying to fuck
with them.
They're trying to kill him while I was
in jail.
This is a plot dead.
Is he still alive?
I don't know,
Dude.
I remember when I was a kid and this
whole John Gotti thing was going down.
I guess I wasn't too kid like I was.
I guess I was in my twenties when he was
in his prime and it was so weird.
I was like,
I didn't understand it.
It was like he was so mocking of the law
enforcement just walking down the street
with fucking,
you know,
$10,000
suits on and get in the limousines.
And it was like,
Whoa,
like this guy doesn't.
He's,
he's ridiculous.
I watched a documentary on the history
channel.
That's not how they're supposed to do
it.
The whole thing about the mob was that
they were all like in the,
on the dl,
like everybody was staying like Vincent
the Chin Gigante,
he's a famous monster,
you know,
one of the reasons why he's famous
because he pretended to be.
He was running everything,
but he pretended to be completely insane
because he knew they were after him,
so he would walk around with slippers on
and a bathrobe over his clothes and just
walked on the street and talk to
himself.
And he would do it all fucking day and
it kept him.
He's crazy.
You can't say he's not crazy.
So everything he says is fucking
useless.
This guy's nuts.
Does he or does he not walk down the
street and his underwear talking to
himself all day long?
Everyday.
Well,
yes,
your honor.
He does,
but I don't think that there's no more
talking.
This guy walks in,
is under it.
Well,
we think he's faking it.
How can you prove?
And then everybody's faking it.
They just want free food.
Who doesn't want free food and a bed?
There's no crazy people.
They're just pretending to be crazy.
So you take care of him,
you know,
he can't say that.
You can't judge whether or not someone's
crazy,
but whoever fucking thought that John
Travolta should be John Gotti.
That motherfucker.
That's crazy.
That's funny though.
It's revenge from the government.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
And let's see,
who could we make his son?
Oh,
his son is being cast by a that the guy,
Justin Bieber.
James Franco.
Which you who?
Yeah.
Who also has some Gaydar action going on
on his side.
He didn't.
He play a gay guy.
Harvey milk played it.
Very well know.
So to Shaun King,
just heterosexual.
Just kidding.
That's the trick.
Knee hating.
No,
it is you hate.
But it is true.
Your DNA.
You from the
idea of kissing men,
even if it's for a fucking movie,
you know,
it's like I got good news and bad news.
Oh,
okay.
Hit me with the good news.
Dude.
You're going to be a fucking movie star.
Shut up for real.
Like a fucking movie.
Cool.
My playing with.
Dude,
you're playing with Sean Penn.
Shut the fuck up.
I'm coStar with sean penn.
Dude,
what's up?
What's up is he gets to fuck you in this
movie.
What's up is you have to make out with
sean penn.
Could you Imagine always wanted to work
with sean penn.
He was a brilliant actor.
Always imagined standing there with him
at an award show.
We're both wearing suits and shit.
We thank the academy were all respeCted
and loved and here this motherfucker is
right there at the door right at the
gate,
but now he's going to make out with Sean
Penn.
What would you do?
What would not do it?
I know.
No,
I'm not interesteD in acting is acting.
To me.
It would have to be something really
fun.
Like I would love to play like wolverine
and an x men movie,
you know,
if there wasn't already guy that played
it like that.
If they offered me something like that,
I'm like,
dude,
I'd love to be wolverine.
I'd get on roids to play wolverine.
Like I need to get yoked,
you know?
But like
that would be a spad as wolverine by the
way.
That'd be crazy because actually need
just training to do what?
That Wesley snipes fight.
That never happened and you became a
crazy bad ass and I can even imagine
like throwing wolverine into the mix.
That would have been
so much fun.
That wesley snipes thing obsessed me for
two months.
I'm really lucky that that didn't
happen.
If I went out fighting him and liking it
and then keeping them in 10 years from
now,
I'm just fucking completely gone.
I'm just forgetting where I leave my
keys every five minutes.
You know,
you're not supposed to start fighting
when you're like 43 where I was.
I was 36,000,
37.
Then.
That's what's crazy about this hershel
walker character,
you know herschel walker football
player,
you know the story behind this swipe
this,
this 48 years old.
Okay.
Heisman trophy winner.
Super athlete just as fucking prime
example of like perfect athleticism.
But this was a long time ago,
a long,
long,
long time ago.
And in this whole time where he hasn't
been playing football,
it's just been a few years.
He stayed in insane shape.
I mean the guy's like super fucking
dedicated to training and now he's like
48 years old.
Going to be 49 soon and he's fighting
this weekend on strikeforce and
showtime.
It's become like an mma fighter.
It's kind of fun,
but it's okay because he could still
fight and all that,
but he's just not going to repair as
fast.
If he gets injured,
he's an amazing shape or it just doesn't
even make sense.
There was no 48 year olds that were
built like that when I was a kid.
When you were 48,
you were someone's dad and maybe had
like old man strength in your arms,
but you probably had a pot belly,
you know,
or at least a little bit of a gut and
you know you're probably scary because
you know you would.
You would hit someone first,
but no one looked like fucking herschel
walker.
Yeah.
He doesn't look like an old man that you
shouldn't fuck with
flex body or something ridiculous,
full fucking eight pack.
Just totally shredded.
Not an ounce of fat on his body.
And here's the crazy shit he says.
He only eats soup and salad.
he has one meal a day,
like everything about this guy screams
that he's a fucking alien or bullshit.
I only eats super sad.
It's all water soluble.
He'd be dying.
It needs meet.
What iS water soluble like?
Yeah,
you will.
You need Protein salad right through the
soup.
It's liquid.
You know,
what's he doing?
That's crazy.
Right?
But why does he say that?
Well,
there.
Here's the other thing,
beCause he wants to.
He his,
his game.
Your dad probably,
but.
Well he's obviously fucking insanely
dedicated but he might be crazy like for
legit,
crazy,
like he's like had like a bunch of
mental,
a bunch of mental health issues in the
past.
The point where he has like some sort of
a.
He has more than one personality.
Was that multiple personalities?
Yeah.
So maybe the part that works out is
different than the part that talks.
The part that talks doesn't get access
to all the interstate shape.
This guy's right up my alley dating
period.
It's a funny thing when you find
yourself date and crazy person just to
get some posting.
Every guy has done it.
Allison,
I think it goes both ways.
I've had my share of crazies.
Is it just to have a boyfriend?
Like fuck it.
I just know it's like where they are
cool for six months and then all of a
sudden it's like what happened to you?
Like they get comfortable with you and
know how,
like what does it freak you out?
So then they Start being their weird
ourselves.
Then you're like,
where did the cool person go that I
said,
well,
there is some kind of game when you
first start dating where you're trying
to be cooler than you are with them,
and then you start farting key in life
is to become that Person.
Become that person who when you first
meet somebody and you can,
it's just we get lazy.
You know you really are that person at
your very best unless you're just a
complete sociopath and you're absolutely
bullshitting about it.
I fucking loved dogs.
MeanwHile,
you're deathly allergic.
You know you could be one of those meds,
but if not,
you know that's what everybody should
aspire to,
right?
You should aspire to be the person that
you pretend you are when you're trying
to get laid.
I could've took that creamer in my
coffee,
but I said,
no,
I'm allergic to.
Why would you take creamer?
Nobody gives a shit if he of creamer in
your coffee or not.
It's Actually more of a bold choice if
you have no cream.
whenever someone wants black coffee and
which you don't even give a fuck about
flavor.
so crazy.
I started drinking coffee black.
I've been trying to sneak a dairy into
her diet without her knowing lately just
because she's allergic to dairy.
Ladies and gentleman.
Yeah.
Well she has this thing,
you know,
she's like,
I,
if someone ever farted around me,
I would just in that relationship,
I wouldn't matter who,
who would be in stuff like that.
So now I'm like,
oh yeah,
we'll see what happens if you start
shitting yourself.
So when you were trying to do is get her
sick because she won't let you.
Right.
Wow.
What a grown up.
By the way,
that kind of 36.
Brian's a grown ass man.
I'm in over my head or trying to get you
to fart.
I was just acting like that crazy
person.
Oh,
okay.
No,
I don't think they added that logically.
You had like a ria.
You're like a nice road.
That was premeditated.
Yeah.
That ain't going to jail for a lot
longer from that shit you think?
Yeah.
You got to walk there and pretend you're
crazy.
I don't even like illegal.
You have to come up With some some
reason for people to think you're crazy.
No.
My mom would ask me,
allison,
juvie.
Gridlocks wasn't tolerant or is it all
in your head?
And I'm like,
why the fuck would it be all in my head
doing that to myself?
People that believe that everything's
all in your head.
All allergies can be with no,
they can't.
Stupid.
right?
Babies are allergic to peanuts and you
give them.
They die,
but you're not allowed to give babies
peanut butter because you have to find
out if they're fucking allergic to
peanuts.
How do you find out?
You got to find out
your milk.
Your milk thing happened later in your
life.
so is there something that broke your
mail,
your milk?
Uh,
yeah.
What,
what was it?
You just had five cheese pizzas when I
was 15 years old and in the lunch line
they had these like cheese and a bagels
that were so good.
So I got one and I ate it and I was
supposed to meet this guy had a crush on
afterschool and I'm walking into his
house and halfway through I'm like,
jesus christ,
I can't walk any for.
Yeah.
I'm like,
mom picked me up because I didn't drive
yet.
So he'd pick me up.
I'm like,
stop at mcdonald's.
And she's like,
what's going on?
I'm like,
I don't fucking know.
The next day I tested it out again.
She ran in the bathroom and the battle
was over.
Did you even check to see if the
toilet's clean?
Sort of a cleansing.
It was a cleansing.
Yeah.
Fucking dirty thing man.
When you have to take a shit in a public
toilet rub and sweaty ass with some
stranger in everybody's sweats on those
things,
man.
Yeah.
Seat cover.
the seat covers are stupid too.
and then like when you're done with it
and it kind of grabs onto the water and
flushes down with it,
you know,
that little arm and shit smeared all
over it.
Okay.
They always look stupid.
It never looks like it's supposed to be
that way.
It never looks neat and tidy.
So you go in there and blast out of your
ass.
And then what?
Did you not go to this guy's house?
No.
Wow.
I never knew what could have happened.
Crush like man's confidence.
You could have changed his whole life.
So that over.
And
we actually wound up dating though.
They're a high school.
So that was the thing though.
That pushed it over the edge.
That was your last year,
first thing,
that and that ever since then,
anything you were maybe,
which is the.
Have you tried just to eat a pizza?
Yeah.
Um,
I could do with like lactose enzymes,
which is like the supplement,
like lactaid or something and pizza.
But if I have it without like five
minutes later.
So that just gives your body.
That's interesting.
have you ever tried raw milk?
Um,
no.
I've tried almond milk.
And all that
raw milk has a that it's not pasteurized
or homogenized,
so it's got all the live cultures in it
and it's supposed to be much easier to
digest.
I've had a bunch of times at whole
foods,
but I don't think they carry it anymore.
I'm not sure if they do,
but I couldn't find it the other day
because a lot of people think it's
creepy because it's,
you know,
it's just fucking run out of the cow's
tit.
Yeah.
And it's in like five days.
It's terrible.
And like after the first couple of days
is good,
but it's kind of not healthy.
That milk just sits in your fucking
refrigerator for two weeks and doesn't
go bad.
That seems like the worst milk you could
ever drink though.
That seems like the most hardest core
milk.
Every job's a tv and yeah it is.
When they milked the cow though,
a lot of the times they get feces on
their hands when they're milking
a little feces.
Feces in your diet keeps you strong.
You need to.
You need to have battles.
We did the your immune system,
you know,
like,
like when you get a flu,
it's good for your immune system,
your immune system fires up and the next
time the food comes around,
the immune system is not so fast.
Bitch.
That's why I never get the flu shot.
Or we'd get a little poop in your body
and your body and then you could fight
off disease better.
We had this podcast last night,
that naughty show,
podcast number.
We had this porn star
on it and she was talking about how she
right after the shoes,
I forget what it was.
She was getting fucked in the ass or
something like that.
And then never in life should you ever
be in a position where like I was
getting fucked,
you know,
whatever,
whatever her name iS,
kelly divine,
you should go look at her twitter.
Okay.
So you can get a better idea of what she
looks like and no one's going to cause
your twitter Page.
And bree olson,
olson's twitter page every day is about,
oh my god,
my pussy sore suck.
So much cock last night.
Just like everyday it's like more and
more brutal.
Crazy.
There's so much that a guy With a two
inch dick would make it feel like a
fucking,
a 10 inch or like she said,
that felt like her tweets.
What's.
yeah,
what's crazy is though,
after he pulled out his dick out a real
ass.
Yeah,
after he pulled out his dick out of her
as he puts it in her mouth and he said
it was just caked with shit,
just so much shit that you know.
And then he fucked her in the mouth and
then in between shoots she had to go to
the bathroom and she said she spent for
like 15 minutes picking shit out from
her teeth and she didn't have any like,
toothpicks or toothpaste.
So she was like,
hi,
what do they pay you for that?
Oh my.
I think it Was like three we own,
but from this guy's dick real.
I've never seen that in a movie,
but I've seen a lot of astrobiology and
I'm always.
I always have the same reaction.
Why is that necessary?
Do we really need to do this?
Turn someone on?
I asked them a lot of people on fucking
dirty I.
Yeah,
and I asked them and does it ever get
better?
does it like turn into chocolate after
awhile where you're just like looking
forward to some shit in your mouth,
you know,
and she's like,
they're like,
no.
It never ever.
Every time.
How many times has she gotten shit?
Her mouth.
Well,
I guess that's pretty common when you,
you,
you do a lot of asda mouth and.
But she said that she was just saying
this one time and take care of god.
That is so crazy.
They pay me all the money in the world.
Part of it is that other girls are doing
it.
All you need is one girl to do it and
it's such a weird thing.
If oNe girl does porn where she left a
guy pissed at her mouth and every girl
is going to start letting go and pitch
their mouths.
It's a weird thing.
It's like all of a sudden that's become
like,
yeah,
It raises the bar and that,
that becomes acceptable to us now asked
to mouth when I was a kid.
No.
Okay.
When you got a ginger,
lynn,
peter north porno,
they had sex at the most.
He shot it in her mouth and it was
pretty hot,
but it didn't stick it in her ass and
then put her mouth.
But that's like standard today.
Yeah,
well that's not anymore.
No,
just under a load in an open mouth.
It's like,
oh,
not this again.
I mean literally you can go on
[inaudible] dot com and look up loads in
the mouth and there'll be like a fucking
100,000
videos of girls with their mouths open
and guys jerking off in their mouth.
She goes through this website you need
to check out because every time she's on
it I'm just like,
wow,
that's a cool video,
but I have a feeling it's one of his
websites that everybody goes to and I
was just the last to know about it.
What's it called?
today's big thing?
Dot com.
I Think I've heard of that before.
It's great.
What is it?
It's just everyday they have this crazy
new videos and stuff like that.
Like they have this one and I do.
They have this one video on there right
now.
It was doing cellos,
have saw that on twitter,
but I didn't click the link and you got
to watch it because it's like they're
trying to be really hard to see what.
I'm sorry.
Do you want to join cellos for the song?
Um,
that an internet,
internet,
internet net.
Oh,
mIchael jackson's beat it.
No,
no,
no.
It's the one that I'm the band also
resaying.
Yeah.
Speed it.
No,
it's not beat it.
It's not smooth.
Criminal.
Yeah.
So we're so wide and so,
so it's um,
so there's like,
like playing the cello,
why?
They're both looking at each other and
they're trying to be hardcore and stuff
and then it starts going the hips thing
and just being like they're fighting but
they're playing cellos and are staring
at it.
It's just,
it gets really good and then it turns
into them like in this weird part where
they're like wrestling in his bedroom or
something like that.
Or in a bar.
I don't even know what it is.
A dark room and cellos are amazing.
Yeah.
The cellos are amazing things that you
can sell advertising today.
If you have guys kissing,
do you think you could sell sell things?
Yeah,
you could.
You could have girls kissing and you
could still sell a porsche.
Yeah,
you know,
but if you have,
could you imagine,
could you imagine if portion,
just like the new ceo just had this
wacky idea.
What I think we need to do is capture
the gay market.
We are missing the gay market.
We'll take chance to push a name is sol
in the american culture.
They love our cars and this guy just
takes a while chance.
So it's just going to get that gay
market to just has to guys like making
out in front of a cayenne,
put hands in the pockets and shit.
You know what the fuck.
And everybody just abandoned them to
audi.
Fuck you bitches.
Fuck your stupid rear engine car.
And they get so many complaints for like
pta mothers.
yeah.
But why?
How come if it was a girl and a girl
kissing with aca compliance only from
fat chicks,
it'd be the only ones complaining.
A few families taking their oversize
hands to cover their teenage sons eyes
while he's watching tv.
Fuck.
I would rather see two girls kissing.
Then two guys kissing.
Yeah,
because that's the first two guys
kissing to get much more Likely rape.
That Is weird though.
That two guys to me still if they're
kissing right in front of me is
tolerable as I am.
I'm still kind of like,
eh,
because tolerant as you are.
If you're tolerant,
that's debatable god.
Except for yourself.
Yeah.
This is a genetic thing,
right?
Do you feel like it's genetic?
I guess I'm not judgmental at all.
I don't have any problem with anybody
doing anything that doesn't hurt anybody
else.
If you want to be gay,
be gay.
It doesn't bother me at all,
but it weirds me out when I'm around gay
guys there making out.
I've been like as close as you are to me
and two guys were were holding hands and
then they just moved in and started
kissing each other into your bed.
No to outside.
I remember distinctly saying,
okay,
don't panic.
You know,
like my boss.
I was like,
don't don't get uncomfortable,
just move away slowly palpitating but
yelling.
Whoa.
They're bugging right now.
Right here.
It's,
it's,
it's so juvenile.
It's like I completely support your
right to do it and I think I'd look at
fucking.
Sometimes it's pretty gross When,
when men and women are doing it in
public,
it was just a lot of people that get
fucking sloppy makeout sessions in
public and it gets pretty narrow
statement.
Yeah,
I support that.
Do that.
I don't have a problem with that.
I don't have a problem with anybody
doing it.
But you got to let gay people straight
people do.
Oh,
absolutely.
I have nothing against it.
It's just,
I'm just saying it's weird that like I
don't,
I could see my two girls kissing,
you know,
my mom doesn't care of two girls were
kissing.
What is your feeling when you see two
guys kissing?
I feel vulnerable.
I feel like don't try to just me.
I like,
if they wouldn't have nothing to do with
me,
man,
you know,
I'm telling you at the time it doesn't
matter,
but it's like with a.
If you know that you're for sure around
a guy who's into guys and it's like all
of a sudden you're in a,
you're in a completely different like
roll,
you know,
you'll,
you'll like,
you can be pursued now,
right?
You could be pursued by a dude like,
no,
no.
Even though,
you know,
I,
I know they don't want everything to do
with me.
It doesn't matter.
I've seen instincts like get the fuck
away.
Yeah.
I've seen two guys kissing and I just
kinda like watched because I was like,
that's interesting.
It just looks different,
you know,
like far as looking at it an alien or
investigating it.
I wish I would if I could be a neuter
for a day.
That's how I feel.
Neutering people.
No,
no.
Like if I wasn't a man or a woman,
if I could be sexless for a day,
then I could probably look at it like
that and like to look at it like that.
Like,
you know,
from a scientific point of view in my
boss is fascinating.
Like what is that like?
That's their return on like I don't
understand like when girls,
anytime a girl is ever been attracted to
me,
I've always been like really?
Like,
what the fuck do you like?
You like guys,
you know,
you like,
like what do you like?
You know,
like it's ridiculous.
Like it doesn't make any sense.
You know,
for a man,
it doesn't make any sense that women are
attracted to men.
I understand they do have a long
lifelong history of experience of seeing
it.
Seeing girls be attracted to men.
So I know it's real.
Right?
But I don't get it.
But when it's a guy and a guys attracted
to a guy,
then it's like,
whoa,
this is like super alien.
right?
We just don't know it.
Something we've never lived or
experienced,
you know?
We're never going to be able to know
what that feels.
And that's,
that's weird with like kids that's weird
with like guys that are into like
fucking horses and all that shit.
Like how do you get the that that's even
going to fucking.
your brain just is broken.
Some people's brains just don't work
work.
Right?
Right.
They just attacked by a man with a foot
fetish at laguna beach.
Tell,
won't tell them the cops and everything.
I'm on.
I'm on the internet now.
Um,
okay.
So anyway,
I'm at the,
I'm at looking at beach with an ex
boyfriend and we're smoking some weed on
the rocks looking at the ocean.
This guy walks up and he a camera in his
hands and he's like,
I think your style is really cool and
really beautiful.
Can I take your picture?
I'm a photography student.
I'm like,
okay,
sounds good.
Mike,
do you mind if I smoke weed?
It's like,
so I keep smoking.
And he started taking my picture and
he's being really cool and he's like,
can I have you take off your shoes?
And I'm like,
uh,
okay.
I think we're at the beach.
I guess this is fitting,
you know,
take pictures of my feet,
start snapping pictures of my feet and
then all of a sudden he gets down on a
knee and I'm like looking at him like,
what's this guy doing that?
And I'm like super high and all of a
sudden he puts my foot on his face and
goes,
he licked it.
Does that make you feel?
I'm like,
whoa.
And I'm looking at my boyfriend sitting
right there and I'm like,
and I'm right in front of your
boyfriend.
Did he not know that you were with the
guy?
No,
he's,
yeah,
he's a crazy guy.
And then I'm like,
what are you doing?
And he's like,
oh,
I want a foot fetish website.
It's California beach feet.com.
And he puts me up on there.
I fucking take the business card because
I'm just super stoned and I'm like,
what just happened?
Check out the website and I'm on there.
She didn't even recently just send a.
Yeah.
I recently emailed him and said I'm
going to cease and desist.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's about dudes Who were into
people's feet.
Did you save it?
The pictures,
the pictures and the video or the video
of it that you should've saved it for.
You take that down.
That's great.
Oh,
It is 25 bucks
before the internet was around,
you know,
like back when,
you had like find things in magazines or
you know,
it's like,
it was a lot different if you wanted to
see some weird shit,
you had a really,
really go out of your way to see it.
There was a,
a magazine called foot.
There was two.
One of them was like this lady boy
magazine and wish I'd Remembered it.
I wish I remember the name of it,
what it was a magazine completely
dedicated to cross dressers and they
were like fucking marines.
These guys were like,
the guy works at the deli.
The guy was bald with a big fat head who
slices salami.
He wants to be a woman and he's got
makeup on and a wig and he's like posing
like a woman and it is fucking tweaky.
It's the,
you knoW,
like look how lovely she looks and you
know,
they'll say that what the woman named
for his character that he plays when he
dresses up is,
it's so fucking strange.
There's this new show coming on.
Um,
were cross dressers,
compete Like In like some cross
dressing,
like reality show I saw a commercial
for.
Have you guys heard of it?
No,
I saw the billboard of it.
It's like,
so it's like,
it's like a,
it's like a game show booth with
crossdressers.
What I was going to say though is that
there was one magazine called foot
action and I remember looking at this
going,
what the fuck is this?
So you got to open it up and check it
out.
And it's all like dudes who jerk off on
feet.
It's a whole thing.
It's like feet on decks and girls
rubbing their feet on decks and it's
like,
that's like a big fucking thing for
dudes.
I don't get it.
That's for standing now for kissing
magazine,
male whole magazine dedicated to its
grass because that guy who took all
those pictures on my feet,
I know he went home and touched himself
to him doing it right now.
Yeah.
What the fuck is if you have a foot
fetish,
if it has a little bit of cotton,
do you get hornier from it?
You know,
like if there's little cotton Between
the toes,
but I would imagine it's like a little
bit of a pussy,
a little
bit of a foot fetish when I was like 18
or 19.
well,
not really.
I just thought they were attractive.
like girls who had pretty feet were
attractive.
It helps.
Yeah.
Just sister sonia feet in Massachusetts.
One girls had like hubs so he goes
walking around kicking ice since they
were a baby or feed feeder.
All jack,
you know,
I don't have a foot fetish,
but I definitely like touching feet.
Like when I sleep I like to touch a
little foot.
I like to hold a foot but I don't like
go after a full day.
No,
but some dudes it becomes a giant focus.
Like that's more important to them than
vaginas or mouths or anything like that.
Something like ms dot firing in the
brain when people are fucking strange
man.
The way one person's brain works and
other persons doesn't.
I was telling you guys about this before
we started the podcast and I saw this
horrible video online or there's two
kids are skateboarding in front of this
guy's house and the guy comes out and
tell them to stop skateboard and they
are like,
fuck,
you can skateboard where we want,
and they they're getting sort of sort of
like a pushing,
shoving,
sort of a little situation and the man
runs into the house and grabs a gun and
guns down these two kids right in the
street.
IT's all in the security live leak,
I'm guessing.
Or it was on youtube because it's not,
it's not that graphic.
You can see him shooting from a security
camera from like the front of his house.
Right?
It's fucking horrible.
You know,
when you think that,
you know,
an argument between someone who wants to
skateboard and some guy who doesn't want
to hear noise can turn into some man
gunning down someone's children.
You know,
they're like 15,
16 years old.
They're like,
kids.
You know it.
She was so fucked up to think that
someone's brain can actually be wired
that way or they just want to go out and
just shoot somebody who's making too
much noise and it's so crazy how random
it is.
Mark,
mark marco that I was telling you about,
he was walking in north hollywood and
some guy just came up to him the other
day,
just put a gun to his head and said,
give me your wallet and your cell phone,
and it's like,
what can happen?
It can happen easy.
There was a guy out here that shot a cop
podcast,
last podcast.
Fuck man.
It's a fucking nutty world and as the
economy gets shittier and shittier,
people get more and more desperate and
more and more things like this are gonna
happen.
Unfortunately,
you know,
there's a lack of balance,
you know?
I don't know how it comes back around,
but it ain't going to come back around
the way we're rocking it right now.
There's just so many fucking criminals
to get guns.
Why don't you have one?
I just don't know.
Well,
I mean it's like,
all right,
you want to get a gun,
it's like 600 bucks.
That's a pretty big purchase,
you know that much.
I'm guessing like decent ones and then
there's probably a thing that you can
kill somebody and it's only 600 bucks
cheaper than that.
It's probably 20 bucks.
If you go in the right places on the
streets and you get a cheap gun,
but you have to do the class too or you
were not collapse.
You have to sign up like two weeks
beforehand or they have to get
background checks.
Do I want to be put in the system and
it's going to take you awhile to get it.
You want to be put in the system to be
put in the system.
That protecting system.
Brian is a,
he's an anarchist.
He stays outside of the system,
hurt libertarian.
He does not believe in this.
Culture is right.
I'm not going to Canada move to
vancouver.
That's why you don't vote.
Right?
So you don'T get put into the system.
I already got put into the system for
the irs though,
so that fucking sucks.
But I don't knoW how that happened.
I didn't do anything.
They just check you bro.
He found me.
They check comics all the time.
Comics get busted all the time.
But the irs.
yeah.
ExcuSe me.
Yeah.
Because comics don't like the charge to
a report.
Money.
Like they'll,
they'll take gigs and they'll get paid
cash.
It was a huge,
huge problem in boston back in the day.
We all got paid cash for all these gigs.
So you got to do your own taxes and most
of these guys are lazy as fuck.
they didn't do anything.
They just took that money.
And then,
you know,
years and years of these comedy clubs
reporting that they have these
employees,
you know,
and then these guys never.
It's just really bad.
So a lot of them are,
you know,
tens of thousands of dollars,
hundreds even,
you know,
over years and years without paying
taxes.
What do you do if you can,
if you can't pay that back,
you gotta pay it back,
pay it back slowly as quick as we can.
So guys,
we're working like every night guys were
taking all these crazy gigs.
Just to try to pay off their irs.
Not see.
I kept withdrawals automatically once a
month and then was pretty much forced.
It's the mom back to john gotti.
Hey.
Yeah.
Right.
So who the fuck else was in line for it?
Was it like barry manilow's busy.
David cassidy can't do it to anybody.
Dude,
she doesn't want to act anymore.
I was going to play john gotti that john
travolta is not a bad ass accurate.
Don't get me wrong,
but that's not the right guy for the
part.
That's ridiculous.
That's silly.
I mean he's great and pulp fiction.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not a john travolta hater.
What?
It had been weird if they use.
Oh yeah,
I would have been kind of cool that I
would have totally.
I've totally would have went for that.
Would it be a good role for stallone to
have been something that he would want
to like try hard at and stretching.
You know,
like when he did cop land,
like he made some,
some the camps a few times.
Good actor.
Yeah.
He can be a great actor and rocky,
but you know,
why do all that hard lifting when you
could just be some bad ass,
some fucking wooden face wouldn't lyric
movie,
you know,
that it just makes $100,000,000,000
in the box office,
you know,
he's the master of those expendable type
movies.
So they sit there and put some jersey
shore guy in there.
I'm sick of all these jersey shore,
like ari was on a audition the other
day,
or a commercial shoot with one of the
guys from jersey shore and him about
like some,
some kind of product.
I don't know if I'm allowed to say there
was a,
uh,
a picture of kim kardashian and,
and she was holding hands like they were
palling around with snooki and they're
both having this incredible belly laugh.
They're leaning back and they're
laughing so hard at all I can think of
is what are these two dumb cunt laugh?
What the fuck are you laughing at?
What,
what,
what did you w who said something funny,
right?
Sneaky.
Probably forwarded them.
Kim kardashians.
Queef too.
Yeah.
So strange.
It's such a strange time we live in and.
No,
no,
no.
When I say dump concept,
say with all love,
I don't really think there.
I mean I think they're just doing their
thing,
you know?
I got no hate for it.
I find it fascinating to watch that
show.
Not one episode,
but I watched it twice or hurt your
brand makes you grip the seat or you
like what is going on.
Like it makes you realize like these are
real people,
man.
This jersey shore is.
They'll fight over anything.
He'll throw shit at each other.
They tackle each other and pull hair and
and turn it.
These crazy slap fights and they know
cameras are on.
They know they don't give a fuck about
these reality shows are,
it's like a bunch of scientists putting
a bunch of rats in a little glass cage
and like,
let's see,
the males meet with all the females can
fight
that.
They're sendIng jersey shore to Italy
for season four.
They just announced in the whatever the
eu,
the italian american interest group
unico or whatever it said that they're
just pissed.
They are so
great.
Well,
those people aren't even all snuggies on
italian,
right?
I don't think they're all italian.
She's like puerto rican or something.
Don't know.
I've never,
I can't believe you were talking about
them,
but we should.
it's fascinating.
We should just like when you go to the
zoo and there's one monkeys throwing
shit at the glass,
you want to,
you know,
it's not like this monkey's beneath me
talking about him.
No man,
that's,
you know,
these are monkeys.
These jersey shore people are just a
different type of monkey.
You can look at it like it's such a
trivial thing to talk about.
Discuss.
But it's really like scientific work.
And what's weird is most of you would
thing
most of them remind me of myself when I
was like 18.
And I was like,
wow,
crew palm may put my bangs up.
I'm going to go,
you know,
like I felt like I was.
But now I look back.
I'm like,
dude,
that is so embarrassing.
But
the product,
look,
this guy,
the situation,
he was however retarded he might come
off.
He's obviously working very hard.
He's got like videos and exercise videos
and he's trying to make something
happen.
ProTein,
vodka.
I don't know.
It probably is.
I mean he's,
he's got a bunch of shit going on.
He's obviously trying to make the most
of the situation,
you know,
when you see guys like that,
you just got to think this is just
someone from a different world.
That's all it is.
It's from a world where you grow up
around people like that and that kind of
behavior is acceptable.
I mean,
I never lived in jersey shore but I was
born in newark and I lived in New Jersey
and I have relatives from New Jersey and
you know,
and I grew up in boston and that
behavior is a lot more fucking common
than you think,
you know,
and if everybody in your house behaves
like that,
it's,
it's like,
what the fuck is that
on the phone?
If that's every day.
I mean That's a real.
Those are real live people out there,
man.
There's a bunch of people that that's
their everyday yelling and screaming at
each other.
Come on,
bro.
This fucking guy does knoW who I am,
This guy has no am
glad I only had two italians growing up
near me or they're monkeys.
That's me.
So I can say it.
I'm three quarter monkey.
They're fucking apes there.
They're squawking apes.
They like to get on top of cars and jump
up and down and bang on.
I'm just like a chimp would all that
yelling and this.
It's not a coincidence that they're the
loudest motherfuckers on the planet.
You know what?
I have a lot of family in New York.
My parents are from brooklyn and all of
my aunts are like the whole,
oh my god.
it's brutal.
But it's funny,
but it's like up there.
Well,
you know what though?
It's fun though.
They're festive people.
You know?
I'm only bullshitting that.
I totally hate it because they have the
best food ever.
I would take italian food over
everything and I am a talent three
quarters of time,
so I can't be that self hating,
but this or that passion that makes it.
It's a crazy race.
You know?
There's some rakes.
Like I liked the armenians.
Armenians are fucking crazy,
man.
Have you ever,
you know,
I mean I know a bunch of armenians from
the ultimate fighter,
from,
you know,
the ufc fights from just training.
A lot of,
a lot of them do jujItsu and those guys
are fucking down to just punch you in
the face.
They're wild.
They're wild dudes.
It's like a whole race of wild dudes,
but that's just the way they are.
I mean,
you know,
if you're born into that situation with
the fuck,
you know,
you know how hard it must be to try to
not be that if you're growing up or on
your dad and you're in a tight knit
family.
So they're all together.
They all act just like each other and
it's fucking 10 of them in a house for
real.
I mean if you there,
those are very family oriented people,
armenians,
they just,
you know,
everyone's over the house.
Grandma,
grandpa,
the other cousins are visiting it just
like they're very family.
They're all like,
they're all like super like intense
people.
Burbank is like filled to the top with
armenians.
Yeah.
And it's like my starbucks and stuff.
They they sit out there and play poker
and like you'd walk in and they all
stare at you by giving you a,
like,
we could trade it.
My friend armand arbit,
the armenian,
my friend armand was a pool player back
in my pool plan days and he was,
this motherfucker would just jam.
We wanted to gamble constantly.
Come on,
you've got no heart.
Come on gamble.
It's a gamble.
Just always wanted to gamble.
Armenians in,
even in pool,
they're like aggressive,
right
in the place where I get my haircut,
which is fantastIc.
Sams or an $8 haircut type place and
there are meetings and there are two
that are all the family members of the
guys that are playing poker outside and
so they kind of know who you are from,
you know,
just go into starbucks every day.
So I sit down and it's the most
uncomfortable haircut cut ever.
Like it fuels,
like I always think that she's going to
take the scissors and just stab it
through my head.
So that's what I'm thinking when I'm
getting my haircut.
I'm like,
don't stab this scissors because it's
very intense.
You need to get a haircut with me and
you want to get a scary,
a very intense armenians or what have
you.
Right.
And it's just.
Which haircut is she?
Gonna fucking snap.
Right.
That's what I'm saying.
If I had those thoughts,
I wouldn't even go anymore.
Well,
intuition was he.
The thing is,
is I,
I go to starbucks every day mixed in
with these people.
Yeah.
Keep your enemies close.
You know,
like,
like if they start throwing grenades,
they're gonna.
Be like,
hey,
you better stand over here man.
You know,
I'd rather have that.
You want to be in with them.
So you say hi to them when you see him.
Hi guys.
I did the nada.
Did they open the door when they're
coming in and out?
I know so far as to make friends with
them.
No,
no,
no.
Don't do that with anybody though.
I was very,
like I told you last week,
I keep very hidden like a ninja low
profile.
Right?
Why is that?
Careers?
I don't know.
Easier,
right?
It's easier to avoid conflict.
Absolutely.
I think I talked to that old man
building your shed in your backyard,
right?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
We talked about his daughter's dogs.
People that just want to start telling
you shit about their life.
Told me a lot.
It's very.
When you get stuck with one of those
motherfuckers and you realize like it
starts off as a normal conversation.
Like what's going on man?
Nothing.
How you doing?
No,
everythIng's good man.
How about yourself?
Well,
it would've been better if it wasn't for
last week.
No,
last week my daughter married this man
and I tried to tell her to stay away
from this fellow,
but she didn't want to listen and you're
like,
oh no,
no,
fuck yeah.
So that's what I try to get out of it
and stay away from is that kind of shit.
That shit is brutal.
That shit was like a beaten woman.
You're afraid of men.
You become a lesbian who become a social
lesbian.
You know who's the best ideas getting
out of this situation.
So that's all you gotta do what you
gotta do on.
He'll make his phone ring.
Yeah,
he'll make his phone ring.
And he's like,
I even saw once when this waitress at
the ice house,
pasadena at his house,
this waitress was talking so much.
Finally he goes,
please,
you're giving me an ear beating.
Seriously,
I need to.
I need to get out of here.
That was like joey diaz meets ernie and
bert.
No.
Who is that oscar the grouch?
Cookie.
Monster cookie.
Monster.
Monster ate cookie.
Okay.
So anyway,
so joey told her that he's,
he's getting it here,
but you're getting the ear beat and just
start going.
Stop.
Yeah.
She took me to say that some people you
cannot,
you cannot hit.
She did that last thing like,
oh,
kind of like feeling being silenced like
that.
Well sort of,
but maybe she's fucking crazy.
Maybe that's the only way to get her
away.
You know,
maybe she would've just sat down with us
and started talking to us.
So some people just don't know.
Some people need those checks just
because there's always going to do it
unless somebody does say something,
be fucking bad ass.
If you could test drive people's brains,
if you could be like,
I wonder how dumb this motherfucker
really is.
Can we just climb inside your head for
five minutes?
Be able to read it someday?
Probably,
yeah.
Malcovich dude.
Have you seen john malcovich lately?
No.
Have you seen it ever being drawn on
liquid?
It's a great movie.
It's a great move.
Yeah,
just rewatch.
imagine if you could pilot,
you know,
if you could like,
I want to know what it feels like to be
a girl.
So you pilot allison?
Yeah,
for like just pilot around the house for
like an hour and shula and she just,
she just stay silent and lets you move
around and look through her eyes.
She knows her in there.
She left In there and you can move.
She goes silent.
You walk around,
you move her body around you finger
yourself.
You can do whatever you want.
You have her body for one hour and then
a trigger to get into sleep with a bunch
of guys.
I don't think I would do that.
Oh definitely.
Finger myself though for sure.
Wouldn't you?
I would do that stuff,
I would pee on myself and all that crap.
You realize when you,
when you start using a flashlight.
Yeah,
sex is way better,
but it's pretty fucking good.
And that's why girls like girls with
dildos,
like I never got that.
I was like,
why don't you stick some
remembered inside yet it's not as good
as a real dick,
but I bet it's probably pretty fucking
close.
You know,
girls.
I would definitely,
if I would,
I would 10 minutes I'd finger myself.
I would try to have sex with another
woman while it was that really tried to
make out with her.
Yeah.
And what have you turned midnight and
turn into a pumpkin.
Like point.
It was like 1158,
you know,
it'd be great right now if I was a guy
and are a girl,
but I'm not attracted to guys ever since
my uncle touched me.
I'm really only attracted to.
Oh shit,
I forgot to tell you I was going to turn
into a dude.
We keep going,
keep going.
That would be cool if you could keep
going because you'd already be horny.
And then she'd be fine,
I creeped out because she just told You
about her uncle and then also in a big
part decks in front of her.
I think if I saw that actually happen,
I would probably freak the fuck out.
Could you imagine just morphing like.
Because there are certain animals that
changed sex,
that's not unusual in nature.
It happens in a bunch of situations.
Certain animals start off as a woman and
they become a male or vice a versa.
And they can change dependent on certain
insects and certain worms and shit.
I think they can change dependent on
whether or not there's enough males or
females in the population.
It's variable.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of like simple organisms
that can do that.
So if simple organisms could do that,
why can't I can't it fucking humans.
That was this part of the movie splice.
You don't even know the movie splice.
Who's amazing movie.
What's that guy's name?
Adrian brody.
I could've bought that movie for a
brilliant scientist.
And what he did was he managed to splice
together.
I don't know what it's like alien,
what it was it like.
And some other shit it was,
it was like a person and some other
shit,
like maybe a frog or something.
They made like this little alien baby
and this is how dumb the premises,
they keep this alien baby app,
this laboratory and it grows into a full
grown human in like a couple of months
and they just keep it in the basement
and they just like hanging out with her
in the basement.
Now all of a sudden she's a chick and
she's kinda hot except her eyes.
You too far apart.
That's like the only thing that he could
tell.
So this thing is like maybe three months
old and it's an attractive woman thing
and he liked it gets scared,
but if it wants to kill you,
okay.
And then maybe three weeks after that he
starts fucking at adrian brody is
fucking this three month old alien baby
thing.
I swear I'll shut that thing off in the
middle of my adrian brody story.
Anything that is,
it's probably the fence toll free
callIng.
well that's pretty weird.
So he starts fuckIng the thing that's
like,
this thing is only a couple of months
old.
I would have not waited that long.
I would have fucked that thing.
The first,
second day look like a girl and it was
like,
oh,
I made you,
wouldn't you?
You would do the same thing.
No,
no,
you wouldn't fuck this.
First of all because it didn't look
totally look like a person.
He had wings.
Okay.
Crazy feat.
It had like the,
like the,
the back
legs were like horse legs.
Did a talk in english.
Uh,
you know,
I made noises,
noises.
It was way retarded.
And then at the end of the movie it
becomes a male.
Something happens,
something happens.
It goes through some really not feeling
well and some weird thing it's going to
die and it becomes a male.
Adrian brody had sex with the male
starts jacking and I think it kills
adrian brody at the end.
I don't remember.
It was so bad.
I couldn't remember.
It was such a dumb movie.
It was like it was over.
You're like,
shut the fuck up.
Know there's no spoilers in this.
But when you,
when the movie sucks tab and we're
allowed to talk about it,
you know,
it's like,
it's fun.
It's fun to watch because it's bad.
Like I was a giggle fest.
So she had boobs.
Like did they have like some,
a little tits?
Yeah.
I said that could have turned me the
right way.
Well,
she's real aggressive too.
And big,
like powerful and shows.
He was really kind of creepy.
BuT she's supposed to.
She's supposed to be four fucking months
old,
you know,
or whatever.
AT the most six.
She said they had to get out of the lab.
You know,
she acts like a child.
She curls up and cuddles with them like
a child and get scared and cries.
But then like,
eat a cat shit.
Did he just start fucking her?
Like raping her?
Did he like her hair first started
making onto him and next thing you know,
he's boehner and I swear to god the
whole theater is howling.
Howling,
laughing.
Yeah.
I mean I was,
I felt bad that I was laughing.
I felt I can't laugh at this.
Fuck.
I'm going to be,
I'm going to be that dick and the movie
theater laughing,
but then other people started laughing
too.
I was going,
oh no.
And then other people started laughing
out loud and then it just became a wave
through the whole theater.
Everybody was just going no what?
The people were just going,
what the fuck ever.
Elma fail.
And that's one of the cool things about
going to see a movie in hollywood.
Like a lot of times we go see a movie in
hollywood.
Like,
you know,
there's a lot of cool people in the
audience.
Sometimes some shit,
stupid,
stupid shit will happen in the movie.
And everyone agrees like everyone is
like,
what is this happened when I was
watching the trailers to inception.
Um,
and it was,
what's that guy making?
He made that movie where everyone's in a
village and they don't know the devil's
it showed like his name in the whole
same thing happened in my theory.
I've been talked about that before.
I've seen it three times that the devil,
when it came on it,
everyone just started going,
oh,
this looks cool.
But that mother of that fucking
disappointing cock sucker,
he needs to change his name.
No man.
I'm telling you.
The devil movie was pretty good.
I liked that movie.
Yeah,
I took a chance.
I'm desperate.
I'm desperate for good horror movie.
But it seems like he's getting gotten to
a point where a lot of people probably
aren't going to watch that movie.
Did not direct this.
I don't think he just produced it bro.
Man,
you might've cost yourself $50 million
bite.
I was doing tech support two months ago
and as I was working from home I'd watch
horror movies over and over again,
like just random ones on netflix.
And I like watched probably
like two a day to the point where like
two weeks went by and I'm like I need to
switch it up.
Like I've been watching this shit too
much.
I had like weird dreams and shit.
Sometimes there's a problem with like
the celebrity pr director,
like the shama lawns boom.
You know,
like because there's a bunch of movies
that are really good movies that don't
have that,
you know,
that doesn't say,
james cameron's boom,
but there's when,
when with certain dudes like their name,
like m night shambhala dinged on is the
number one.
His name is just immediately associated
with all of his movies.
Did he fail at that?
Everybody hates him so much.
Also go one with the sixth sense was the
last good one.
Wider.
Unbreakable was okay,
but it was really slow.
But then there was the water one was so
dumb and the plant one and I didn't even
see the plant one,
but everybody told me to plant one was
fucking god awful.
Did you see the plant one and now
happening?
I saw now a gang of them that made me
nuts.
Yeah.
I saw.
I forget which ones I can't remember,
but I still take chances.
I'm a sheep big film.
What'd you?
Friday night.
The big film with cozy it.
Fuck it.
I'll just sit there and try to watch it,
man,
sit there with my popcorn and try not to
think this is stupid,
but that was a good movie that the devil
was not bad.
It was.
It was tricky.
It was good enough.
You know,
it was a,
a good horror movie,
you know?
I expected it to.
Soccer did not fucking not enough.
Good horror movies out tHere,
man.
Couldn't monster movie.
I think the human centipede was the last
one I Watched.
Was it more just gore of I want to see
monsters when somebody makes some good
models.
Do you see human centipede?
I got and I didn't want.
I watch it for the creek festival.
I mean it's one of those movies I was
going to turn off after the first 20
minutes.
I just wanted to get a taste of it,
but then I kind of got addicted to the
fact that it was so creepy and I was
just like,
I got to see what's happening here.
I mean,
it's not good.
I don't like it,
but it's,
it's,
it's definitely worth seeing just
because the characters in it are fucking
creepy as fuck.
Have you seen that?
Maybe shutter island?
Yes.
Okay.
That one was not surprising and
whatever,
but there's a movie called madhouse and
it wasn't surprising because you kind of
knew it was going to Happen.
It's like,
oh,
he's obviously going to be the crazy
person.
That movie was a hot subject of debate
amongst me and my friends.
Really?
Yeah.
Most of us thought like I went to see
you with sikora and with uh,
eddie bravo and uh,
they both.
We all thought that it Was a bad movie.
I felt like you can't just show me a
bunch of shit and then say,
oh,
psych.
He was crazy the whole time.
It was all a dream.
If you go on like a netflix look at
madhouse just like shutter island,
but with like unknown actors,
really completely better story.
Better ending.
Like I wished that one made it to
theaters.
yeah,
the shutter island,
whenever it looked bad ass and it seemed
kind of interesting,
but when you found out that he was
crazy,
like halfway there was,
there was one point in time when you
kind of knew that things were a little
wonky,
like okay,
this is all of a sudden we've entered
into this unrealistic micozzie climbing
up these mountains,
you know,
and by the ocean,
remember that part by the ocean when
climbed in the cave.
Right.
And how can you start thinking,
okay,
obviously it's crazy like it's going on,
but you can't have a movie where you
have everything makes sense and then all
the sudden it doesn't.
And oh,
it was a dream.
Like that's like a cheap trick,
like a slap in the face to all the
viewers.
Yeah,
I mean I get,
I get,
you're trying to be crafty.
It just,
I don't think it's successful.
I don't,
I didn't think it was good.
I wonder how some of these get put out
and pass all the people they need to
pass and then it gets such bad viewer
responses.
Well,
the big part about the whole movie
business is the producers.
The big part about the movie business is
that people that come up with the money,
so it's not just,
well,
it's a bunch of different people get
involved.
They,
you know,
it's not just the people who wrote it or
the people who were performing the
characters.
There's a lot of other shit behind the
scenes,
you know,
and there's a lot of cooks and
everybody's got their own idea of what
you should be in and should be not.
And I've seen a bunch Of things that
were really good,
get fucked up a bunch of things.
The man show and doug and I did it.
That got all fucked up by other people
involved looking at the screen,
worn it movie man.
Have you seen the premium that looks
like somebody.
I was going to say that the best example
there was,
um,
there was a movie that I did a long time
ago.
It was a terrible movie.
It was called frank mccluskey.
Cei or pii private investigator,
I think it was.
Anyway,
it was this kid,
I forget his name,
dave,
who's the lead,
who's a really funny guy,
and uh,
he was doing all these different.
I Should respect to him find out what
the fuck his last name is at green horn
immediAte looks fucking now I'm
wondering if it's supposed to be funny,
but what I'm saying is with this guy,
when I did this,
this movie,
I'm dave sheridan,
that's his name,
did this movie,
this fucking kid.
It's hilarious.
And he would have in him and his friend
wrote it,
right?
So he had like,
they were like going over the scenes and
what's the best way to make them funny
and,
and the dude was really good.
Like he's a really good actor.
He was in like,
like I'm a scary movie and it's been in
a bunch of different films.
So anyway,
he's,
he's performing the scene and it like
he'll come in and,
and hit it his way,
but there's all these.
No one knows who this guy is,
right?
So there's all these suits in the room
and these guys would like fucking
expensive cufflinks and rolex watches
and suspenders.
And they're given this dude literally
giving him takes like do it like this.
Like when you walk in,
I want you to blow like this.
I watched this guy do this and I'm like,
this is what happens.
When these motherfuckers get power,
they all of a sudden they think that
their creative,
all of a sudden they want.
They want to influence the these,
these funny people making their shit.
just because you've backed a bunch of
movies and you've got a bunch of
successful movies under your belt,
doesn't mean you know how to make
something funnier,
but they all just want to get their
greasy fingerprints on it.
Like it's a big problem in hollywood.
It's like no one lets like the smaller
the group,
the better.
That's what it's got to be.
The smaller the group,
the better.
And you can't make what they're doing
better.
You can't go in and go,
no,
you guys are focusing too much on this.
It's too much that you've got to bring
it back and make it like you.
All you're going to do is cause chaos.
All you're going to do is interrupt.
So either they make something that you
enjoy or they don't,
but you can't add to the process.
It's like saying if you were,
if someone was building car,
they're making a porsche
and you're like,
I don't like the way this front end
looks what I want the front end to be.
Stick up like this.
It's like a cobra.
Like it's coming at you.
And they'd go,
hey,
that doesn't work.
Because there's aero dynamics.
Like we need aerodynamics.
He scientifically,
it doesn't work,
but I think it would really work.
We got to figure out a way to make this
work.
And he'd be like,
well,
did this,
this is stupid.
You're not a car designer.
What's the same thing with these
assholes?
They're not,
they're not funny.
They're not actors,
they're not comedians.
They're just fucking people with money
that have financed a bunch of movies and
get it.
Yeah.
So if you're doing a tv show,
if you're doing a movie,
there's a bunch of different people that
have their say,
you know,
that's how john travolta gets cast as
john gotti.
There's a bunch you know and you know
you're looking at a guy like that.
You're like,
okay,
so big name.
We'll get john travolta,
john travolta,
regati.
It's very controversial.
Maybe we should go with it.
It's going to get a lot of press.
John travolta's gotti.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
meanwhile,
back at the ranch,
I guarantee you if we find the guy who
wrote that thing,
he's probably fucking pulling his hair
out.
John drove a whole dog freely.
The previous work of all time for john
gotti.
I was a fucking.
I was undercover.
I wrote this book.
I wore a wire.
You pop socket.
My life,
my family's life.
I'm fucking john travolta.
Don't they love him for Greece though?
Not anymore.
No,
no.
After this picture of the inquire of him
kissing another man.
Really interesting you say I'm getting
off as yet and there's a picture of him
kissing a bunch of people that know him
that he said it online that have said in
interviews that thought it was like out.
I thought it was like,
you know,
there was a big article and like think
it was vanity fair.
Some,
some dude that drove walter used to
bone,
just talked about how,
you know,
he would just go to bath houses and shit
and just hook up.
Remember the family guide with the last
family guy,
I think it was where it shows the Greece
where they fly out into the air,
like in the car and then it was like
the,
the bonus thing that they cut out the
movie where they're just like,
oh my god,
it's cold up here.
And that's cool up here,
you know,
because they're just flying through the
sky and then she's like a warm me up,
you know,
hold me,
warm me up.
He goes,
hey,
I'm good.
A gay joke.
Did your volt down?
Yeah,
that's funny.
You know,
I,
I understand that if he was gay and I'm
not saying he is because I don't know,
you know,
but if he was,
I totally understand them not wanting to
tell people because of his business.
You don't get to play the lead in movies
if they know you're gay because there's
just a big chunk of America like you
know,
fucking probably 30 or 40 percent.
This is just not going to go see a movie
where john travolta is kissing girls and
it has a girlfriend or a wife.
If you know that he's,
he's gay,
don't you usually get to a certain point
in money at least or where you don't
need to worry about not getting lead
roles anymore.
You could still probably make money,
you know,
if.
Especially if you're gay to commercials
or that's easier said than done.
Man.
You know,
a
lot of people don't want to disappoint
their fans.
A lot of people were worried.
One of the reasons why,
you know,
certain alleged organizations protect
their members from homosexual,
you know,
rumors and all,
all,
you know,
anybody finding out that they're gay,
it's because they're trying to protect
them as a business.
They're trying to use like a systematic
approach as a business to maximize their
opportunity.
Look,
if you can come out,
but if you do,
here's what's gonna happen.
First of all,
you're only going to come out to
strangers.
You're friends all know you're gay
anyway,
right?
That's all that matters.
Your friends and if you come out,
there's a bunch of roles you're not
going to get.
There's a bunch of things you're going
to get pushed away for and you just
might be a few opportunities that you
miss and when it's all over what's write
a book,
but write a book will say you get,
but for now,
let's say you're name.
Okay.
And we'll throw in a couple of quirks
are or perks.
Likely.
Yeah.
You can be that the woman in hairspray.
Sure.
Every girl.
Yeah.
It's kinda funny.
You know,
it's a fucking interesting thing man,
though,
the way the human sexual system is
wired,
there is this ad that are maybe like a
preview on the news and it's like oprah
tells a big secret like next week at
four and I'm like,
isn't it always kind of questioned?
But she's a white man,
white man.
No one ever saw that coming.
Oprah.
Yeah.
What is,
what was the secret?
I don't know.
I don't think it aired yet.
Her Big secret is that she's going to be
a lesbian.
And with that girl,
right?
People think that already.
A lot of people think that I uh,
why?
What did you just bring up oprah?
Like I was watching over it on the news,
like bring chicks to the shoeburg.
Start bringing.
When do I watch oprah?
I watch it occasionally and just so just
see.
It's like,
I just need to know that that site
existed.
He sits,
scribed a day.
Oprah channel,
joe.
Uh,
no I haven't.
You have to pay for it.
I'll watch it would,
you know,
I mean I will every now and then just to
see what the fuck is up.
I watch everything,
man.
I watched hunting shows.
I watch super,
super right wing political shows.
I watch.
I watch people like a scientist,
like I just want to know what the fuck
is out there.
You know,
I don't watch a lot.
A lot of shit.
I don't watch for entertainment.
I watched,
I just watched to see what is this,
you know,
a go,
so many shows man,
like religious shows.
I love watching religious shows.
Do they watch steve harvey on this
religious?
It was fucking awesome.
First of all,
he's crying about the pressures of being
famous.
It was amazing.
You know it was piece of cats,
don't know.
Cats don't know what it's like,
like complaining about being this
multi-multi millionaire celebrity and
then he started talking about god and it
was just brilliant.
It was just amazing stuff.
He was saying.
He was like,
what did he say?
It goes,
if you can't,
don't have god in his life,
I don't even want to talk to you.
You're silly.
Silly person was awesome.
Like if you don't believe in god,
you're a silly person.
Friend do that to me.
She told me,
allison,
we can't be friends anymore because
you're not a woman of god.
And I'm like,
bitch,
I was fucking just started kissing her.
is that what I should have checked her
oil?
Say,
shut up bitch.
You want to taste your pussy?
Stuck my fingers in your pussy.
Things like bad
girl,
bad girl.
She just would've went right with it.
Their dirty little bitch.
Yeah.
So what?
What did,
how was the conclusion?
Did you guys break up?
No more friendly.
We're besties.
Yeah.
I know.
We kind of met up I guess a year ago,
but this happened like when you were 15
and I was like,
are you crazy?
Yeah.
So french righteous little cunt.
Yeah,
it was weird.
That's ridiculous.
You don't know what the fuck is up and
you're 15.
You did go to catholic school.
I went to catholic school for like four
years.
Yeah.
it was rough.
So much guilt and strain and stress and
so many people that come from guilt and
strain and stress have their kids in
there.
So there's fucking straining in the
home.
Wow.
Fucking want.
I will just repression.
And so one of the most depressing
religions.
Yeah.
I didn't like it at all.
better.
Used to go to confession for like once a
week and I'm like,
I'm not doing this.
And I got kicked out in ninth grade.
I went to public school.
Sounds like religion.
They would have gotten me if I was like,
what?
The mormons or something like that or
someone fun.
So it looks like they have a good time.
I have friends that are mormons.
When they go to church,
it's like basically you sit around with
a bunch of people's families,
you say some nice things about god and
you'll leave.
Nobody feels like shit.
Nobody feels like a fucking center.
Like a piece of shit.
I talked to two mormons and be like a
couple months ago while they were
walking around and I was on a jog,
we started talking and I said,
oh,
you guys don't ever have a time to
relax,
go see a movie or whatever.
And they're like,
no,
we can only rest for seven hours on
wednesday.
And that's what we do our laundry.
but the rest of the time we're scouting
around and knocking on people's doors.
Oh the,
okay.
You're talking about missionaries.
People are on a mission.
This isn't like,
you know,
everybody has an app to do that.
No,
these are just the people that want to
like go and recruit people.
Bicycle.
And then I think they called them elders
or something like that.
Elder john.
I'm like,
what's your name?
fucking hilarious.
As a young dude coming up to you,
colin,
self elder the fuck out of here.
Pretty hard.
This,
uh,
this person that I know that is a
mormon,
I'm just recently,
they've completely abandoned it,
so it's been kind of fascinating.
So they had some things happen to them
in their life and they just decided the
religion really doesn't make sense
anymore.
It's kind of weird.
So weird wHen that happens,
man,
when all of a sudden someone just goes,
oh,
what was I doing?
Like I knew people that used to be
christians,
like we're super super christian and
then they just kinda lightened up on it.
But you know,
like rampage jackson at one point in
time,
wouldn't swear,
wouldn't stop swearing,
didn't want to have premarital sex.
So we got married,
like the whole deal went super full
blown christian.
So that was just the gIrl making them do
that.
Probably.
I don't know.
I don't know man.
I think at some point in time people get
real,
real nervous and they really want to
believe that there's an answer.
You know?
They really want to believe that someone
who's got a book from 3000 years ago
with all the shit in it,
it's all in here,
man.
It's all in here.
You can live a perfect life and if
you're around people that really,
truly believe in,
here's the deal,
man.
It fucking works.
If you were around someone who's a real
true,
practicing christian,
I mean,
think about what that is for a real,
true practicing,
practicing christian.
You are just doing christian things.
You're trying to be loving and love your
neighbor and do charitable for your
community.
I mean,
that's really what it's supposed to be
all about and if you do that,
that really will make you a happier
person.
So it does work,
you know,
even though it's,
it's the reason why it works is because
you're tricking yourself into believing
that this 2000 year old book written by
people thought the world was flat in the
son was 17 miles away,
has all the fucking answers.
That's ridiculous.
But,
but the,
the fact that if you believe in
something like that,
it's like a placebo effect for your
life.
Yeah,
I was actually at work and one of my
bosses,
he's a pastor also and he hands me that
rick warren's book and he's like,
what is that?
It's like rick warren,
like the chosen path.
It's a catholic or a christian book that
a pastor wrote.
It's like one of the best selling books
ever really told the um,
the crazy ones are with the,
is it,
is it two guys?
They have like some whole fucking,
a whole series of like super,
super,
super popular books,
but it's all about like the apocalypse.
You don't know about this?
Yeah,
there's,
I think there's a group of two guys and
they're like the best selling authors in
America and people don't even know about
them.
God,
I got to find this out right now.
I hate when this happens with these.
Did you read the religious book?
No,
he handed it to me and I was like,
what's this far?
And he's just like,
I want you to read this.
And I'm like,
well I don't want to read this so you
could have it back.
And he's like,
why don't you want to read it?
It's just like a briefing on the bible
and whatnot,
and I just told him,
even though he's a pastor,
like I don't want to read this.
Let's say I'm at work right now.
I don't need to read this.
Here's the guys.
There's two guys named tim lahaye and
Jerry Jenkins and they write.
This book's called the left behind
series and were these lives and made
them into movies and I have two of them
have both of them because they're
fucking awesome.
And there were kirk cameron and it's all
about how jesus comes back and everybody
dies,
but the christians get taken to heaven
and everybody here is fucked.
Do they get left behind?
It's like fictional.
Oh yeah.
They believe it is the apocalypse.
This is the real shit.
God's going to come back and if you're
not saved,
that's why these not banks like kirk
kirk cameron.
That's what you see him talking to gang
bangers and,
and you know,
trying to get them to,
you know,
to,
to come to god.
Like he really believes that jesus is
going to just show up and everybody's
going to be taken to heaven and
everybody else is going to be stuck and
fucked and left back behind here on
earth in a godless world with no laws
and all the good christian to be gone
and there'll be stuck here.
He really believes that and it's.
These books are fucking huge,
huge,
huge sellers like millions and millions
of copies.
Some of the most successful books in
America.
Some of the most successful fiction or
crazy shit lately.
Full of shit.
And he's just dolla.
Dolla bills.
well I don't think so man.
I think they started out probably you
can.
I don't know man.
You think they're full of shit
completely.
Who knows man.
I mean look at like all these people
that ever get in trouble for like,
you know,
I think he's gay.
If religious guys,
if I had a bet money on kirk cameron
being gay or not gay dude,
he had a perm when he goes on.
Growing parents.
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean anything.
So did.
I'm trying to think of somebody good.
I think tommy morrison and made a perm
at one point in time,
he has aids
bad example,
but um,
when I see him like trying to convert
people and i'M like,
what are you running froM doing?
Why Are you so into this?
What's,
what's that about why or why is that
consuming your,
your humanism?
It's a,
it's a gay thing or my kid's game game
money and money and thanks.
So
I don't know.
To me it just seems like it's a smart
thing that he's doing the same reason
why there's clean comics.
You had seen that,
but this guy
goes into,
has like debates against like scientists
and they look really stupid.
Him and his buddy,
he's got a buddy that has a,
I forget this fucking buddies is
buddies.
Retard ray comfort and never seen the
banana thing,
right?
Where it says of the banana was designed
by god and this is how we can prove it.
He shows the banana fIts in your hand.
Then he peels the banana and eats it and
shows.
This is the,
this is a,
um,
an evolutionist nightmare because this
is like clear evidence of creation that
god has created this fruit.
Like you fucking really meant that when
he was saying it,
guy created a dick.
It also fits in the hand.
It also gives you juice when you were
thirsty after killing dinosaurs.
But no,
no,
the,
he has to do that kind of shit though.
In order for him to make this money.
He didn't,
to be legit to several of these books,
he has to also do bullshit like that,
you know,
you would be,
have to be a way better actor than he's
capable of because these two guys were
so dominant,
these debates and they're,
they're so fascinating.
There's no way you could not believe
what they're saying and say the things
they're saying,
unless it's like one big gigantic,
you know,
multi-decade hustle.
I don't think so.
I think they're just knuckleheads,
you know,
I think there's knuckleheads and they
get married to an idea and then they
just stick with that motherfucker.
Whether it makes sense or not.
but these dudes,
these left behind dudes.
I want to know what,
what their circulation is.
Mm,
sure you do,
baby.
That's their circuit asian.
Um,
shit.
By the way,
oprah disclosed that,
that at her news was that she has a half
sister.
She didn't know about what?
That's news.
How ridiculous is that?
How is that news?
Right.
Everything was oprah's news.
I mean,
it's kind of like when you get put in
that certain class of why is that news
will black lady and what is it that
doesn't make any sense.
I can't find out how many books just
think sold not quickly,
but it was a fuckload officially a fuck
load of books.
That's all about these people being left
behind.
It's fucking awesome.
If you ever want to get blazed and watch
kirk cameron rocks,
it's really
rather growing pain.
that would be good to at least stay like
tracy golds in there and you know,
get.
Ooh,
let's get some tracy gold.
I've been paying attention to what's
going on in yellowstone.
Yellowstone national park,
you know,
has a called dara super volcano that
erupts every six to 800,000
years and just fucking continent killer.
It kills almost everything on the
content killed like two thirds of all
living things on,
on north America.
Well,
uh,
the,
magma has been bulging and it's got
these bulging pocket swells where the
earth is lifting and there's all these
forms,
these photos of them online and the
questions starting to freak out.
When are we,
they don't know.
We'll see.
It's been about 600,000
years.
So it could,
it really could happen.
They're not,
they were concerned.
They said they were concerned for
awhile,
but then they're not now they're not
anymore because it stopped doing what
they were worried it could do.
But the bottom line is it's completely
unpredictable.
They don't know what,
when,
when it can happen or why it happens or
what causes it when they say it's a
contract killer,
like I could destroy the whole
continent.
Is that like maximum?
And the minimum is like,
oh,
it will ruin like the taco bell next
door,
you know?
Well this is what it is,
dude.
It's 300 kilometers wide and it's a
super volcano,
which means when it blows up,
you know,
uh,
mount saint helens is a volcano and then
at the top there was a small area where
all the water was shooting up in the
air.
Well this isn't like that with this is
like the top part,
but the top part is a 160 miles wide and
it shoots straight up in the air like a
fucking mile high wall of love,
agitate.
And then steve.
Yeah.
And then nuclear winter occurs because
the entire surface of the earth gets
covered in fucking ash.
Like no planes can fly.
Remember that little tiny baby as
volcanic blew up in Iceland and
everybody got fucked.
Nobody can even fly anywhere.
But when this one blows,
it's they do anything.
Like take the drill holes in it.
No,
no,
no.
This is way too big.
You got to move to Australia,
bitch,
move to Australia and have some canned
food waiting.
Seriously.
If that motherfucker goes,
if that mother fucker goes,
it's going to go.
You probably won't be able to do
anything.
You probably won't be able to get out in
time.
If we find out tomorrow that yellowstone
is going to blow.
What are we gonna do?
Where are we going to go to san diego?
That's why I keep that in my car job,
my my emergency kit at all.
I hope that thing has a motor boat and
you're going to have to get the fuck put
in there.
That's a good idea to get one of those
rafts blowup raffing.
Sure.
Because you know in Australia when it
was fucking when,
when these crazy floods hit,
there were sharks in the street.
Sharks.
people spotted sharks.
Bull sharks swimming down the street.
That's how much water.
There wasn't Australia bringing guns.
New molten lava was just coming and
there is no escape.
You kill yourself.
It's not even that.
It's not.
The molten lava was goIng to fuck you.
Yeah,
that's bad.
Lab is terrible,
but when it's all the other stuff that's
going to get you to the toxic rain,
the fucking shit and the air wick,
it fills your lungs up and kills you.
Like a lot of animals,
like they found all these woolly
mammoths and they were all dead and um,
they were dead in like this mask,
like field of them.
And one of the things they found was
that their lungs were all filled with
like sit.
Her lungs were filled with like volcanic
ash.
And so what happened was they just got
caught in some big volcano eruption and
then just breathe in all that smoke and
it literally turned their,
their,
their lungs into rocks and they just
die.
You know,
you gotta lungs filled with volcanic ash
and it's like volcanic rocks,
you know,
basically in your body.
It's terrible.
Yeah.
It cuts off your air.
You can't breathe.
You're all.
You mean the air is thick with this shit
and they all died.
Have you ever thought you'd get one of
those chemical max that you can get?
Like at surplus stores?
You know,
like when you need that chemical mask,
everybody's dead anyway,
you know,
if you needed that mean,
what are you going to do?
You're gonna,
you're gonna.
Be mad max.
You're gonna.
Be out there on your own.
Go walk around and humps him dead ladies
and grabbed some wallets.
I dunno,
a certain point in time.
You got to say nighty night a heaven or
hell,
and I did kill myself in that situation.
I hope that they'd be like,
it's okay.
We get it.
No.
See they don't get it.
There's no exception.
That king
kill yourself.
Kill yourself before you suffocate to
death or molten lava that attacks your
body.
Like molten lava probably gives you a
really quick.
I mean if you fell in a bit,
have you felt on a volcano?
We'd take like one second.
You would just disappear.
Volcanoes and that's called.
How long could you last?
That's what they used to do,
man.
In Hawaii,
people are douche bags.
They throw him in fucking palae they
throw in a volcano man,
until he got rid of cons.
Yeah,
he's.
Yeah.
That's how they get rid of people.
That's how they execute them back in the
day sun back when motherfuckers wearing
skirts.
You know what I'm saying?
Throwing spears at animals and shit
sacrificed wild wild pigs and shit.
That'd be a wild place to live,
throwing people in a volcano.
There was a documentary on the lost
tribes and all these different people
that are still living in elected live
thousands of years ago,
all over the world.
And uh,
I was watching it and I was thinking to
myself,
man,
what the fuck would I do if it all went
back to this?
How would I,
would I even want to go back to this?
Like what if society ended and all of a
sudden you're making bows and arrows out
of bamboo trees and making your own
twine.
You're trying to feed your family by
hunting food.
Fuck man.
Really?
What,
why,
why would you think that would be kind
of like,
be like camping.
And he'd be like fun for like a week and
then you're like,
I'm fucking hungry.
There's nothing to eat around here
except this bird that won't sit still
and I need to make a,
I
guess what,
there's not that many animals.
It's not nearly as many as you would
need to sustain a population.
Okay.
You know,
we think of,
you know,
we'll go hunting.
Well,
you know,
there's no animals to hunt anymore.
It's not like it used to be 300 years
ago where you could go anywhere near
here and it'd be deer everywhere and all
sorts of other animals to eat.
Like we pushed all those bitches out.
There's nothing left.
You know,
occasionally you'll see a deer in
hollywood,
you know,
like,
um,
you ever drive up laurel canyon and see
a dear family and shit.
It's a trip,
you know,
it's like,
wow,
you guys are still here.
Huh?
Me that yesterday.
If you ever see it around here,
it seems very empty and we'd be fucked.
We'd have to start eating each other
probably.
No,
definitely dogs first.
Then people.
There's no other food.
How many fucking cows are they around
here?
If you've got no more cars.
Okay.
Cars don't work anymore.
Let's just get crazy.
Right?
What are you going to do?
You got no phones will start eating
people,
right?
Yeah.
And then you're going to probably kill
yourself.
You gotta try to figure out a way to
kill yourself after you've eaten a few
people and you feel bad.
Yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
I couldn't person.
Would you rather die?
Uh,
yeah.
I would kill myself before I hear a
person.
Speaking of killing yourself,
this fucking bath salts thing.
Have you heard about this?
Yeah.
I have this craziness.
This is for the folks that haven't
heard,
and this is not a joke.
This isn't the onion.
Okay.
This is the huffington post,
which is sometimes almost as funny as
the onion,
but in a different way.
Anyway,
this is what they're saying is that
there's chemicals that are sold as bath
salts and people are taking these and
again high with them and it's making
people like crazy suicidal,
do a nutty shit.
Like there's one guy took a skinning
knife,
it says slit his face and stomach
repeatedly.
He survived,
but other people haven't been lucky as
was snorting or injecting and snorting
powder such as innocuous sounding names
as ivory wave read,
dove and vanilla sky.
So it basically turns you into some
fucking homicidal suicidal maniac.
That's crazy.
Who was the first person who did that?
Fuck.
Yeah,
I mean,
what?
What is it about people that were so
desperate to change our state of
consciousness,
so desperate to get drunk or high or
speak in which you're fucking drunk.
CasT.
Okay.
I've been meaning to do this
intervention and do it on the air
because this is an intervention.
I need to talk to the both of you.
Okay.
You can't drink like that that often?
No,
we don't do that.
You're gonna die and you're going to die
on camera.
You're going to have fucking liver
failure on camera and that's going to be
a sad show.
We waited like 10 days between the both.
You fine me.
His motherfucking calls me up.
You got research.
I got you sick,
dude.
I saw you fucking shit.
Faced slurring.
Hammered on the ustream.
Bato jaeger bottle.
Jaeger master.
you're blaming me for you being sick.
Shut the fuck up,
man.
Yeah,
you pulled should be sick.
You crazy.
Fuck nuts.
Still sick.
So what they do is for the folks at home
to do not know about this,
they do this thing called the drunk
cast.
He calls it blackout cast or drunk cast
and he's done it a few times and they do
it.
Sometimes they do it and they watched
the ufc,
which is pretty cool.
they'll watch the fights and then like
while the fights are going on,
all these comics are commentating on it.
It's really funny,
you know,
like joey's over there and sam trIpoli
and tb and um,
well the latest thing is they drank a
whole fucking bottle of jaeger and just
get completely.
It's like an hour or tWo.
It was not,
it was not like the promise.
We've done
two of that blackout cast,
which is where we take a whole bottle
and we start going crazy.
First one was the jaeger might've jaeger
meister bottle and we did that in like
an hour and then don't remember the last
half of it to remember the next day for
the first couple of hours,
you know,
I don't remember anything.
Then the second one we didn't feel like
when you watch the video,
that one was funny because it was.
Yeah.
But the last one was so bad.
You took it down.
I.
Well,
I'm debating on it because the problem
was,
is the ufc drunk casts was right before
it and we got sloshed on the drunk cast,
like we wasted at the end of the,
the,
the last one.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
we decided like an hour later,
hey,
we're still drinking,
let's do a black outcast.
But then we were so wasted that we,
we couldn't even think of what to drink.
So we're drinking coconut water with
vodka.
We were doing just like straightened
morgan's good.
It was actually good.
It was pretty good.
Did you do it over the rocks,
huh?
Yeah,
it was good.
It takes a,
took off the edge of the vodkas that
tastes like or take a walk.
But we had like,
we had jaeger vodka beer and captain
morgan.
Right.
And were drinking all those mixes two
days in a row.
So two days in a row.
You're basically drinking cast is when?
No,
that was an hour before we started this
blog post.
The same day.
It was an hour hour podcasts in the same
day.
Oh,
I thought it was the day before.
Oh my god,
that's ridiculous.
No poor fuck it was.
I don't think you should post it because
we just got so on social.
It was a.
It was like this.
This is an impersonation of most of the.
Of the law.
That blog out one good.
Leave it.
Leave it up.
Dude.
That's important man.
That's part of the entertainment.
That's.
Listen,
that's part of the entertainment value.
We don't.
People have to watch it.
you're not forcing them.
You're not charging them for it.
It's up there.
Leave it up there and maybe I'll put the
audio,
but the video,
the videos.
How bout this?
How bout we record?
We take the video and record you guys
doing commentary.
That would be funny and we have it
playing on and then get it to a certain
point where it's like,
were you just not even talking anymore?
And then just start explaining things
and what was going through my head.
Should I puke now or should I?
Can I hold it in or can I get to the
bathroom?
Keeping on camera.
Yeah.
I tried.
There was a part where I get a bag in a
bag and then she ended up puking you and
you ended up licking his fleshlight you
should've thrown out.
That was at the ufc drunk.
He did that.
That was how drunk she was at the usc
drunk has.
I mean,
we really were like bad.
That last one.
I don't know if I can.
I think the secret is starting off
completely sober and then drinking a
whole bottle in an hour or something.
Did the porn stars touch your
flashlight?
No,
they wouldn't.
They were like,
I'm not going to touch that.
That's hilarious.
It girls pickets shit out of her teeth
with her fingernails and she said the
flashlight and then allison kissed it.
She didn't clean.
It was clean,
right?
I listened.
It's washed,
but the bottom line is,
well,
it's like shaking hands with a dude.
If you shake hands with the dude,
you're basically touching his dick
because every guy touched his dick and
the odds of him having washed his hands
after he touched his dick before he
touches your hands,
they're like 70 percent against most of
the times.
You know,
when you're not around,
we were always grabbing our dicks and
moving it around or grabbing our balls.
Like you shake your hand,
you're touching his balls.
There's one point in the drunk cat.
So which,
this,
this is true.
We kiss a girl.
You're sucking someone's deck.
I don't think I ever told you this.
This is a true story,
a crazy story.
Uh,
so I used to work at this mexican
restaurant and I was a waiter and the
waitresses were,
there was 1:18
year old waitress,
like three slash 17 year old waitresses.
They're all fucking hot and they all had
a crush on me.
It's important of music.
And so anyways,
uh,
I started having sex with the 18 year
old hostess player back in the day.
She had a party once.
Where did she invited all the hostesses
and was.
So it was me,
her,
and like three other hostesses were all
getting wasted drinking.
I bought them alcohol because that's
what I like to do.
But anyways,
uh,
the party starters here,
I was like,
how can I make out with all these,
take advantage of all these girls at the
same time?
And so I thought up this idea where I
took saran wrap and I would put it in
between my mouth and the girl's mouth
go,
if you want to make out,
you're not touching me so we can pretty
much make out as much as you want and
we'll feel real.
They were like,
holy shit,
that's awesome.
And so I would just start making out
old.
Were you when I was 18 and they were 18
and they fell for this 13 year old.
No,
no,
no.
It was great.
It's like I would on a couple of the
girls that had a little hole in the
thing that I find my tongue and they
wouldn't have noticed because it felt it
feels real.
And then I started taking saran wrap and
putting on my hands.
But like I can touch your boobs because
I'm not actually touching a serial
killer.
And this is a,
this is a good move.
Yeah.
And so I did that.
We were so drunk I started getting mad.
So tell me more about this move.
So the girls let you do that?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
All of them.
No,
it was up the shirt making out and this
shirt and they were drawn to it.
You just have.
And what was so funny is,
is that the girls could feel,
when I put my hand up with the plastic
on,
like it was like not like half,
like the saran wrap wasn't covering my
hand half the time to do that and it was
just like,
dude,
this move is awesome.
Wild julian.
Julian assange is in jail for rape for
way less than that.
Right.
And so then then the one girl I was
fucking with,
like I went and had sex with her and
whatever that later that night,
and they all,
the other girls like passed out in the
living room.
I came out and this one girl was like
still awake,
horny.
And she called me over.
He started making out and we had sex in
there and then it led to sex even.
So.
So you think you started a competition
by filling up all these girls and being
the only male,
right?
You,
you started a competition,
right?
You created an unfair game.
It was a very smart move.
It was very similar to.
The pound was strong.
So I,
I pulled them out on allison and feel
real.
It feels real,
right?
Like it felt completely real.
Pulled them little young kids out there.
He's like,
I'll use saran wrap.
I'm like,
okay,
so why don't you use condoms?
You don't even really fucking.
That's what you're pretty much doing
face condoms and condoms.
Wow.
Pitch that.
The trojan.
Yeah.
If you had a really strong plastic,
like really strong one and you could put
your whole body and cover your entire
body in this sheet of plastic.
Sure.
Let's try it out.
Look,
I can show you how real it feels.
Do you want to make out scene on,
on today's show?
How dare you on today's big thing.
That website said earlier,
they had this thing where it's called
the creepiest man alive and he blows
himself up in balloons and he sits in
there and hangs out.
I wouldn't say he's the creepiest man
alive if you need to get online.
Right.
It's titled the title.
They're just being silly or it's not
really the creepy.
That would be hilarious if I lived in a
balloon,
invited girls into my balloon.
The best thing ever,
and it's what's called today's big
thing,
not today's big thing.
Dot com can never fucking keep track.
All these sites are now.
That's a good one.
Very good one.
Today's big thing.com.
There's just.
when is the internet ever going to run
out a website?
Addresses?
I don't know because that just start
adding more dots.
Dots,
dots.
It's always weird when you're like,
dot,
are you?
Hey,
his fucking.
We tried to.
We tried to give me a virus.
Jack.
MY jack,
my shit.
If I look at it like a russian website,
I go,
ooh,
red Romania.
I was reading this thing and I'm a.
I believe it was in wired about this one
area of Romania that has like a,
just a gigantic percentage of the
world's hackers and they're all driving
around like mercedes benz's and they're
all like,
you know,
like young,
loud mouth kids that just hackers,
just jacking people all these scams,
like how many times a week do you get,
you know,
dear sirs,
I need help from you and in exchange you
will have access to my grandfather's
fortunate of,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is and this is what
I need you to do.
How many of those.
Again,
I got one today that was so hilarious.
That was from microsoft xbox award show
soccer at g mail or something like that.
And it says,
oh my goodness,
you have won the grand prize for the
microsoft word national holiday,
something like that.
Sponsored by soccer.
You have another.
Can you pull it out?
Let me see if I can pull it up.
I,
oh,
those are the best in the nation.
They're from Nigeria.
I wonder if I can get that.
I don't give a fuck.
And Nigeria,
winter of microsoft,
Nigeria is the wild,
wild west,
wild,
wild west.
But I loved how they were throwing in so
many key words that even if my mom saw
it,
she probably be like,
well,
it is from microsoft word,
you know?
Uh,
hold on right.
Here we go.
[inaudible] shit.
Did I delete that?
So it came in as spam?
No,
it came into my inbox,
but I think I marked it as spam,
so I don't know what happens to that.
Check your trash.
I did check it.
It's not there.
[inaudible].
I don't have it anymore.
Oh brian.
But I literally just put it on.
Oh,
here it is.
No,
I got it.
Great.
I got a wHole section.
I saved my email.
The wording on this right here it goes.
It's from microsoft.
Two thousand 11 g mail at f,
fifa World cup lottery.com.
It says,
dear winner,
please check the attachment below.
And it says,
dear winter,
microsoft corporation management
worldwide are pleased to inform you that
you are a winner of your annual
microsoft word lottery lottery.
It saYs it twice conducted in africa,
being the host of the present fifa world
cup,
mega jackpot winning program,
your personal gmail address or company
email attached to the microsoft word
with serial number.
You are lucky number and you won.
You tHerefore been approved for lumpsums
of one point one $900,
million thousand payable in cash
credited to file number bet.
Something from total prize money of $50
million united state dollars,
whatever.
What are they asking for?
It says protect.
Our participants were selected from
g-mail worldwide websites throughout our
microsoft computer ballot system,
drawing from 21,000
names,
blah,
blah blah.
So what do they need you doing?
So then it says there's some phone
numbers and it gives some emails,
which would be great if we could call
this person right now.
It says it must be claimed.
I have to fill out this thing in order
to avoid mistakes.
Yeah.
Well,
okay.
What do you have to do?
What do you do?
You need to give them money?
No,
it says the name,
address,
nationality,
sex,
age,
occupation.
Um,
no.
It looks like I just have to call this
person back and that's when they start
asking for numbers.
Yeah.
And they probably,
when they get all that information,
like name and all that jazz,
they probably zoom in on you than they
do an internet search for you and then
they just start targeting you and going
after you.
I liked this asis,
lottery sponsors,
sponsors,
microsoft corporations,
and then it's just photos of all these
pictures of people winning state
lotteries area.
It's ridiculous.
I got,
I get a bunch of different kinds.
Some of them that are like,
they're like,
you know,
it's a different kind of scan.
Like this one I got the other day.
uh,
I don't know who the fuck this guy is.
So is ryan keegan?
I have no idea.
I don't know any ryan keegan's.
Hey,
how you doing?
I made a trip to london two days back.
God mugged at gunpoint last night.
All cash credit card and phone was
stolen.
I got messed up in another country.
I'm stranded in london.
It was a bitter and I was
hurting my right hand,
but I think I'd be just fine.
I'm sending you this message because I
don't want anyone to panic.
I want you to keep it that way.
For now,
my return flight leaves in a few hours,
but I'm having trouble sorting out my
hotel bills,
wondering if you loan me some dollars to
sort out the hotel bills and also take a
cab to the airport about $2,500.
I've been to the embassy but they aren't
helping issues have.
I have limited means of getting out of
here,
so I really need your help,
but I guess he sends this to like,
you know,
I guess you send this to like a million
people and you get a few bites and all
you need is a few bites.
If you could do this with a computer,
if a computer can generate a whole
gigantic email list that you can steal
from something or buy like a lot of
them,
I bet you can buy them.
You know what I mean?
There's a bunch of different
corporations for sure that they've gone
on a business and you.
You ordered something online and they
sell your email address and they have a
database.
They sell their database,
it doesn't matter.
It just amazes me that they're so.
They're also stupid sounding like,
like at least go,
hey,
well,
let's talk about.
We talked about earlier the waitress
that wouldn't shut the fuck up.
The joey diaz had to give him a beating
too to tell her,
you give me an ear beating or if you
took that woman and all of a sudden she
gets this email,
right?
I don't.
Who are you?
Where do we know each other?
They should add something like,
hey,
have you seen black swan yet?
That was awesome.
Like they can make was stuck in london,
man talking about box.
Microsoft word.
Me too.
Anyways,
I need money.
He gets one old retired woman who has
alzheimer's and just like,
oh my gosh,
where I am.
Those people out there,
there's a lot of little little like
manboys out there too.
There's a lot of people that are like
children.
you could take their money.
That's,
oh my god.
I talked to this photographer and he has
a friend that does this organization
called project child safe where they get
a bunch of money together and this guy
flies out to other countries and takes
back like kidnapped kids,
like the movie taken and brings them
back here.
Yeah,
I guess like the government has nothing
to do with it.
It's all like privately run and the do
nothing right now.
Wow.
That is a lot of gunfire.
I would imagine.
Like a stolen kid for my family are
pretty much kidnapping,
but they go to other countries.
Right.
That's scary.
Shit.
That's.
That's a good.
That's a good reality.
Show project child safe.
No shit,
but I bet you couldn't fault it would be
a little conspicuous running around with
a gun in their hand,
sneaking around the corner with fucking
camera guy and like a boom.
Here's another one that I got that was a
much more subtle one.
Attention.
How are you doing?
Hope?
Fine.
Question mark.
Sorry for the late email update.
I want to make fast contact with Mr.
David deutsch in regards to your
released project fund
and some.
Why do you save them?
I save them all.
I just save them all.
I got one from the first bank of Nigeria
from 2009 that I saved.
It's a collector's item.
Listen to this unread.
Listened to the first line.
The first bank of Nigeria.
Remember that?
Listen,
this one dear.
This letter is written to you in order
to change your life from today.
Grab me so far.
I'm riveted.
I am mr James lewis,
the director,
international remittance department of
this bank,
comma,
my boss,
Mr.
Jacobs.
No comma,
just a slight space am smith comma the
managing director,
ceo of this bank is now on compulsory
leave and all power have been vested on
me to make all international payments
from Nigeria.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
It's so bad.
It's like,
do you have microsoft word?
Motherfucker?
What did you run this shit through?
Google translate paint brush and text
edit.
They must've just raN it through a
translation program,
right?
They don't know what the fuck they're
saying.
That's what it is.
It's been translated like they do it
millions and millions and millions.
There's a part of me that is absolutely
fascinated by this because what I'm
getting here,
right,
okay.
I'm sitting in front of my computer and
I'm getting this direct connection with
some fucking guides who are basically
like gollum from the lord of the rings.
you know what I mean?
Like think of like some of the people in
Nigeria see the somali pirates and all
these fucking nuts.
They got me.
It's A wild,
crazy savage world there and they're
just millions and millions of email just
trying to fuck people out of their
money.
How are you getting any.
That's what these guys are doing.
Episode of intervention on annie and
I'm.
One of the guys was getting
interventioned because he was addicted
to replying to those kinds of spam
emails.
He blew his whole retirement and he'd be
on the phone with africa and they'd be
like,
we need 30 more dollars.
He's like,
okay,
I'm right on it.
And he's like,
I'm not getting scammed.
I'm just waiting for my prize money.
And his family is like,
he does this intervention intervention.
Yeah.
That,
that they shouldn't even waste a show on
that guy.
They should just slap them,
you know,
they stopped them a couple times wasting
a show.
It's fascinating.
You know,
we,
we talked about tHis one guy that was
getting scammed by these are nigerian
dudes and they pretended that they were
hot check and it was a famous porno star
and they used her photos and this poor
fucking guys,
you know,
like the sad old 60 year old man and he
thought that it was real.
I thought that he was really going to
meet this is his queen.
What happening?
This dummy flew to london 14 times,
14 times for whatever reason they could
never quite hook up.
There's a good website called for 19
eater.com
and they pretty much just screw over all
the scammers.
THat's really a whole website for 19
eater.com
is like a yelp for scammers.
It's,
it's like opposite trolling baiting.
Right.
Stan was stan hope used to do that all
the time.
Standing up piece to bait child
molesters.
I think you read a book about it.
Did he?
Didn't he publish all of them as a book
or something?
It seems like it to do it for a job or I
only did it for,
to be doug.
Stan hope that's just how stan ho brock
said he was,
um,
contacting these,
uh,
these child molesters and then it take
all the,
like,
all the fucked up shit that do we say to
them,
you know,
pretending he was like a little kid and
they would,
uh,
put it online.
There was a whole website,
[inaudible] dot org.
Remember that?
Yeah.
It's still around.
I don't
think so,
but that for 19 is awesome.
You gotta check that out.
There's like the,
the hall of fame,
the trophy room where,
you know,
in these
people debating dot orgs here because
it.
Yep.
This is,
we'll welcome to [inaudible] dot org.
One of the most fucked up sites on the
internet due to the massive amount of
sexual content on this site.
We felt it was in everybody's best
interest to give you the phone
disclaimer and then you go in and it's
all.
It's the whole thing is all them baiting
child molesters.
It's the fucking standup stuff though,
if you could find it.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of them.
You could see him nearby stan hope and
their god damn genius.
you know,
I think half of my lung is filled with
incense.
You got some crazy insect that was like
incident log,
fire log of innocent.
That's the real shit man.
I get the front of the jamaicans outside
of the house of blues.
Is it too much?
It's almost like I feel like I don't
have any air breathing and 100 percent
I'll kill it.
Don't be a pussy.
Meanwhile you smoke cigarettes.
I know my eyes are watering though.
We're all like [inaudible].
Do you feel it?
Like it feels like it's just thick now
that you're saying and I'm noticing it,
but I wasn't noticing it before.
Oh,
you know what I'm trying to do,
man.
I'll try to recreate what it used to be
like back in the day when I started out
in the comedy because I was mad and he
could just go into a smoky room when you
knew that just dark shit was gonna
happen
about those smoky rooms,
man,
where you just,
you just knew.
No one's taking care of.
They're healthier,
right?
This is,
this is a place of deviance.
That's,
you know,
that's why I used to love smokey pool
halls.
Pool balls used to be the best.
He'd go In to clock in the morning,
packed in a thick cloud of cigarette
smoke.
yeah.
It's probably not so good for you,
but something about it.
It's just got the worst.
Is waking up the next day though in
smelling your clothes.
Oh god.
Even as a smoker that.
That's disgusting.
Yeah.
They stIll have one of those in orange
county near where I live,
um,
to bar with the pool tables and stuff.
And you could smoke cigarettes inside.
I was having this conversation with a
buddy of mine about those natural
cigarettes.
Are those things any better for you?
I don't think so.
It's like vapor and there's like no
carcinogens in it or something like a
little bit,
but it's still tobacco,
right?
Smoking tobacco is not good for you.
Right?
well,
there's no smoke.
That's correct.
It's kind of like,
what are you talking about?
I'm talking about cigarettes,
electronic cigarettes,
cigarettes.
I said natural,
like those,
those american spirits things like are
those better for you or better for you
because it doesn't have like 102 other
chemicals in it and.
YeaH.
Yeah.
So yeah,
it's better for you than having a
marlboro light.
It is,
but I also have noticed when I smoke
those,
it's like,
it takes forever.
Like it's like two hours.
It's like I'm smoking 20 minutes instead
of five minutes.
You know,
it's like a bonfire.
Just not the same.
It's good.
I like it,
but it's.
If it feels like you're,
you're smoking more bonfire.
That's
an Interesting way of describing it.
Like when you get smoke in your mouth,
when you're near a fire,
it's like you cough on it tastes nasty
leafy and drive like,
ooh,
that doesn't sound good.
Let me go old bites.
He barely even feel like you're smoking,
you know?
It just feels calming or something.
I don't mind tobacco man.
I liked tobacco in the form of cigars.
Tobacco,
When you smoke a big cigar,
like especially if they have like a big
meal and have a big cigar.
so garza gives you like a weird buzz man
if you're trying to pipe what's her,
even if you're not in like inhaling Mr.
Guy.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
Because he just comes into your blood's
dry,
uh,
your uh,
your bloodstream through your mouth
immediately.
By the way.
A lot of people don't know that,
but like anytime there's smoke in your
mouth,
it's almost immediately in your blood
sweat.
That's when people say like,
I'm not going to inhale this weed.
You know?
You're still getting fucking stone.
Yeah.
As bill clinton,
you dumb so fucking dumb.
I didn't inhale.
we.
Okay,
good.
Did he didn't get as high,
right?
You still got high silly.
You should not get high on andy.
Got bath salts pretty high.
Are they gonna start recalling
basketball.
Yeah.
They're making some bath salts illegal
in Ireland right now.
It's an epidemic all across the world.
I wonder what it'd be like.
The snort mr.
Bubble dude,
this shit.
It's a weird thing is it's the names of
it.
Ivory wave,
bliss,
white,
lightning,
hurricane charley chemicals can cause
hallucinations,
paranoia,
rapid heart rates and suicidal thoughts.
It makes you attack yourself and it
makes your nose smell great.
You know what your body is probably.
Your body's probably so mad that you're
such a dumb cunt that you snort bath
salts that your body's like,
oh,
we're going to kill ourselves now.
All right.
You want to do this bitch?
You want to do this?
Get a knife.
Well,
can't you?
I mean,
you can pretty much get fucked up on
almost anything if you want to get
fucked up to the point where you want to
slash your face off.
I mean,
they're listening to the things that
people are doing,
man.
They're like,
they're like attacking themselves.
Yeah.
They're still conscious and alive and
causes.
Apparently it's super,
um,
the stimulants and our neurotransmitters
in the brain.
They're saying and this stuff,
mp mdpv and method drone or they're made
in the lab and there aren't regulated
because they're not marketed for human
consumption.
So these things are in these bath salts.
How the fuck is this stuff in bass off
that's like,
you're like taking a bath with crank.
Like this is what you're doing.
You're taking a bath with pcp.
Why was that in there?
Isn't it supposed to be salt?
What the fuck is going on?
And trips your pores open and then you
know,
it gets in there and washes around.
It causes intense cravings for it and
they'll binge on it for three to four
days before they show up in an er and
even though it's a horrible trip,
they want to do it again and again.
It's incredibly addictive.
Wow.
This is nuts.
Twenty five states have received calls
about exposure,
including Nevada and California.
Louisiana leads with the greatest number
of calls at 165.
One hundred and 65 fucking people.
I need to go to bed,
bath and beyond tonight.
Wow,
this is crazy.
You might as well try it before they
recall it.
We stock up on it.
This is really nuts.
Forty eight different calls are 38
different calls.
It's like the highest demanded drug.
Now soap cast that.
That's what strange,
strange thing that all of a sudden they
figured out that they get smart.
It's almost like you found another hole
in the system.
Like people want to get high.
So bad.
You know,
the fall we found this new shit.
Hundreds of people are doing this.
This is crazy.
Wow.
Apparently it's not something you do
recreational.
It's not like you're going to try to.
I didn't like it.
He'd do it and you get a face slash and
zombie.
Wow.
This is nuts,
man.
I wonder if you could just do a little
bit less of it and not turn into a face
slash name is already.
Maybe they're just doing way too much.
He kind of like,
whoa,
here it is.
This is what they're saying.
The problem grew in rural Mississippi.
After a law began restricting the sale
of pseudo f,
f a dream,
the key ingredient,
and making methamphetamine
pseudoephedrine pseudoephedrine.
So when they stopped selling that stuff,
we're restricting the sale of it.
They couldn't get meth anymore,
so they got crazy and then they tried
this shit.
This is worse than math.
This is something that's fucking up meth
heads.
Like they used to just be meth heads and
then they started doing bass to cutting
their faces off.
I want to hear about the kids who tried
it,
who started this phenomenon.
I don't think it was the kids.
Yeah,
but it wasn't kids really.
Governor happened.
I bet there was some fucking crazy guy
like in that breaking bad show.
There was some,
some,
some sort of a scientist character and
he realized that bath salts will fuck
you up to.
So just started giving them to people.
That's possible,
but you can't even corner that market if
you tell them it's bath salts.
So they must have held at gunpoint to
get the secret sauce.
This is the greatest fucking crack of
all time,
man.
Shit,
I'm taking over the world.
Listen to co.
Just magic getting to the point.
Remember when you used to get those
things for christmas where it was like a
bag of bath salts,
you know,
it was like a decorative item given to
you by,
uh,
like,
have you seen them?
It looks like a snowball,
right?
And that's going to be like your,
your,
your april is one of those.
Wow.
There aren't the,
aren't regulated.
That's the real problem.
Meanwhile,
they just made fucking five methoxy
dimethyltryptamine illegal.
They made.
It's super illegal.
Now you can't get it anywhere.
If you have it,
you're in trouble.
That shit used to be able to.
You still have buying online five
methoxy dimethyltryptamine,
which is the most potent form of dmt
used to be able to buy it online.
Yeah,
you can buy a jug of it and just get
blasted on it till the end of time.
Now it's a schedule one.
Yeah.
Now it's right there with a.
With a marijuana.
Yeah.
Used to be able to just buy it.
It's weird and then someone figured out
like,
hey,
you can get really high off this shit,
and you just buy it online.
That's pretty silly.
If you get caught with acid,
you go to jail forever.
Not forever,
but you get caught with anything.
Anything like acid or playing footsies
me here.
If you get caught with any kind of acid,
you know any,
any,
anything where they think you're doing
that.
When you're making your own drugs,
that's.
That's even crazier than mushrooms or
pot because you're.
What are you doing?
You're.
You're synthesizing a chemicals
specifically for the purpose of getting
people fucked up.
A,
you're a.
You're a special case.
You're in a fucking.
You know,
you got like rubber gloves and shit and
a lab coat on and your in your bathtub
and you're making enough acid to get
like a whole state high.
You can make a.
You can make enough acid in your bathtub
to get like a million people
excellently.
Splashing it onto your.
Oh my god,
it took me five years to make disaster
because every time I would die for like
two months.
I met this girl a couple years ago and
she told me that she has this friend who
obviously went crazy,
moved away to a different state,
but she got pulled over by the cops and
had a whole vial of acid on her and she
drank.
She tripped for like 60 days and fucking
like split town and like,
it's been a weirdo ever since.
I never met the girl.
God,
why don't you just pour it on the ground
are ridiculous.
Or just
start going doon,
doon,
doon gould who do come to life.
It becomes a transformer.
Wow.
I've heard stories about people.
That's the number one drug that I've
heard stories about.
People losing their shit on.
Yeah.
Just breaking,
you know,
just see,
you broke it broke it I think.
I think acid in any,
like any secondary given dmt.
I think if you do it a certain amount of
times,
you're probably not going to be the same
as before.
I knew what do to did it 100 times and
he totally became crazy.
He just was doing dmt all the time to
the point where when he would do dmt,
dmt entities would talk to him and go,
do,
do you get to stop coming here to settle
the fuck down and killing our bus.
Dmt.
And when you have a dmt experience,
like a lot of it is marked by
communication with whatever the fuck it
is.
You could be that you're communicating
with some other part of your
consciousness that you don't normally
have access to.
Or it could be the great beyond like
this well of souls or it could be aliens
and another dimension.
You're communicating with something.
Whatever it is is really just
speculative.
But this guy,
when he would go over there,
the dmt,
whatever he was connecting to,
what's going on?
Dude?
Dude,
dude,
stop.
Stop smoking.
Bmp everyday.
This is crazy funny.
When the dmt spirits are actually
annoyed with you.
Come on dude,
come here all the time.
Whether they fucking eat my food,
your stinky feet or on my couch the fuck
bro.
Get it together.
That's funny.
Yeah.
You know,
man,
until they figure out a way to let
people do whatever the fuck they want
with their bodies.
Do whatever the fuck you want.
You're going to always have a gang of
different drug problems.
Where people are afraid of though is
that when you start making everything
legal,
well then you know,
we'll put kid could get a hold of it and
everyone could get addicted and that is
definitely true.
You do run those problems.
You do run a chance there being a little
bit of a spike
once it becomes initially legal,
but you,
you,
you're gonna have to let people learn.
You have to raise your kids and tell
them to never do that shit.
You have to be around other people that
raise their kids and tell them,
you know,
don't do math.
It's gonna.
Kill you.
I don't do heroin.
It's bad for you.
You could smoke pot.
It's not going to hurt you if you drank,
let me know.
I want to be there.
I want to let you know.
I want to make sure you don't drive home
drunk.
You know,
like you can.
People can navigate their way through a
lot of different substances and the
society if you just allowed us to,
you know,
but as soon as you start making shit
illegal and restricting the,
you know,
the access to a bunch of different
things,
people can't figure out what's good and
what's bad.
That's why there's a lot of people to
think that mushrooms will fuck your mind
up.
Know and that smoke pot,
you're become a lazy piece of shit.
Why?
Because they don't have access to it.
If they have,
if everybody had access to it,
especially wheat,
if everybody had access to,
we'd,
we would all think of it the same way
that stoners think of it stolen or is
pretty much universally look at pot and
say,
well,
it's very beneficial to me.
It calms me down.
It gives you perspective.
It makes me silly and then there's the
medical uses for it all.
I mean,
it's like universal amongst the people
that use it.
Well,
how come the other people don't share
that opinion?
Well,
it's because they're not using it.
It's really that simple.
The people that are anti pot,
it's possible that you have some weird
reaction to pot,
in which case I would say,
hey,
don't do it.
You know,
you don't have to do it,
but I guarantee you if you're not doing
it and you're describing what it is you
don't know or they a mom or a dad or
brother that was like lazy as shit while
they spoke to me,
is that like,
oh no,
I totally get that.
And I'm like,
no,
it's not like that.
Your brother is fucking lazy.
They don't see enough ambitious donors
out there.
People don't understand it.
It will give you a different perspective
and it might not necessarily be a better
perspective,
but it's good to look at things a
different way all the time.
Every now and then rather,
you know,
if you look at things the exact same
way,
you can get locked into sort of a mental
pattern where you think that things make
sense,
you know,
and then you need like a,
a good,
good,
really fucking good real good bake
session where you just completely float
away,
you know,
when you and your friends are sitting
around like how many times did we had
these conversations like especially like
after shows or were just completely
barbecued,
like eating dinner and we're all just
like breaking down the universe or
figuring out life or just having these
conversations where you almost connect.
Can't get there on your own.
You don't.
There's some conversations with you.
You get to when you're high and you're
like,
man,
I don't think I can take responsibility
for this conversation.
I don't think I ever would have got
here.
Everyone was on high,
you know?
Of course a lot of those conversations
are not as cool as they would be in
there.
Just talking about how fritos would be
getting a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich.
You know,
I like those talks.
I was really,
really nice marijuana driven talks
because you can't get that when you're
hammered.
No,
no,
you don't.
Right.
It's more like a good,
a good stone
conversation.
Not a dumb one,
but a good one.
You know everybody's kind of in that
grove man.
You figured out a lot of shit in those
conversations.
The nick swardson have a jaguar,
a,
I don't know.
No category.
They just put on tmz that he.
Somebody stole his jaguar
last week outside the improv on a friday
night,
but it happens or he's just trolling
tmz.
Do you think you would troll dmz?
I don't see him having.
He didn't have.
You can't say that you got your car
stolen.
They can find that out pretty easily
unless there's that lazy.
Well not the felony to tell tmz ally
behind it.
Not just telling tmz.
Tmz.
You just can say whatever.
Yeah.
You can say whatever the fuck you want
those concepts.
The whole.
The fucking jim norton.
Over this weekend I saw jim norton at
cap city comedy club and I was in
austin.
I was down in austin for the fight for
the troops and I had friday off,
so I went to cap city at norton,
had some of the funniest fucking jokes
on tiger woods.
Oh my god.
He was killing me and mel gibson,
he was fucking killing me dude.
Really,
really funny shit.
Putting out with them after.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We,
we went out to eat and club soda.
Kenny was there and chris,
chris from the flusher joe.
Yeah.
He's a good guy.
And uh,
but it was just,
it was so fun and refreshing and right
when I think that,
like I always start thinking maybe I
have too many dick jokes.
Like why is my sense of humor so
juvenile,
like it's always like someone sucking
dicks or some dick goes in there or you
know,
whatever.
It just becomes a dick joke somewhere or
another.
I mean,
time machine jokes become dick jokes.
Just I have a really juvenile sense of
humor.
And I was like,
maybe there's a problem with that.
I know.
That's what I like.
Well maybe I should expand that out.
Let me try to like,
relax.
And then I saw norton and every other
job was a dick joke and I fucking how
old all the way through.
Like it literally every other joke and
we had a conversation about it.
I go,
you like gave me like positive
affirmation.
Like sometimes I worry that I have too
many dick jokes.
He goes,
oh,
I never think about that.
Think about that because that's what I
think about some of them.
Sick fucking person.
He's funny,
man.
He was really funny.
It was refreshing.
It's good to see,
you know,
we work all the time.
It's like I don't get to see like a,
a full headliner set that's like real
rare that I get to see someone in a
comedy club working and just be an
audience member and sit down there.
So it was cool man.
It was fucking,
I was howling.
But here's a weird thing,
man.
There was these two local comics that
were watching and the fucking,
he was killing.
Okay.
Norton was fucking killing.
And these two guys were watching like
this hate or sad faced just totally dead
face.
And I was like,
wow,
that's weird.
Like,
do you don't think this is.
I was crying,
laughing,
you know,
at certain points.
I mean,
it's just really well crafted jokes.
Really funny here.
This bit about tiger woods,
about.
I don't,
I don't want to do it.
I don't want to fuck it up.
I don't want to paraphrase it,
I don't want to ruin it.
But uh,
I was crying,
I was fucking crying and I looked over.
These guys are stone faced haters,
haters.
Also.
They're trying to,
they're probably fascinated like it's a
big deal to be working with a big name.
Jim norton's a big name national act,
you know,
so then they get to work with them.
Then they're judging their own
performance against his.
Trying to think of there better than his
jealousy with comedy,
especially the,
the,
the guys,
they were like,
I could do
better than this person.
Well there's a lot of guys that are just
starting out or they've been doing it
for a couple of years that for some
reason they feel like your success like
takes away from their success and they
should have more success when they do
look.
Very weird thing,
man,
to be a person that wants to be on stage
with their voice amplified in a
spotlight on you.
You've got to be fucked up.
And I'm talking as one of them and I'm
talking to two other ones.
You guys are both comics,
you know,
you both do stand up,
you've got to be fucking crazy to want
to do that.
And so a lot of these people,
they're like so desperate to even out
their life,
they're so desperate to finally get some
success.
So desperate to put it all together and
have the big picture in front of them
and finally move on past this disaster
of a childhood that they,
you know,
they didn't want to claim ownership of
their life.
So they get like super hyper ambitious.
I met people who are like,
you know,
I hate sand up.
I just get up on stage because it's
challenging for me,
but I hated every second of it.
And I'm like,
that's strange.
Who says that
you can be good and say that you have to
suck this period.
Except steve martin.
Steve martin didn't like standing up in
the end,
you know,
he was a,
it was too easy for them apparently,
and he was awesome.
You know,
let's get small.
That's some fucking great shit.
Like I remember when the jerk came out,
steve martin was holding
various johnson navan sounds like a
typical day.
Fun shit man.
He was a funny,
funny comedian man,
but he just got too crazy.
He would,
he would.
He was so big that everything he said
got laughs and like he lost perspective
and like,
you know,
we stopped doing it.
He was so good.
He had a stop
man.
He,
he,
he was such a let down for me because I
was such a huge.
Steve martin was the letdown.
It was just,
you know,
that that part like around sergeant
bilko years where he just kind of lost
the part that was funny to me about
them.
It's like I can't really tell what it
is.
It's exactly what it is.
Just age I guess.
So it happens to all of them.
It happens to almost everyone.
It's very difficult to maintain a sense
of humor as first of all,
as your body starts to decay and second
of all,
as you have all these relationship
problems,
which they always do.
No,
you just have these fantastic weddings.
It turn into bitter divorces and then
you wonder,
well,
this is it.
I'm here already and now I'm 45 or
something like that and um,
I'm a movie star and I'm making all this
money and I don't even enjoy myself and
I don't even enjoy the product and what
is funny anymore.
And when you're not doing stand up,
when you don't have that immediate,
for me at least i would not be
confident.
And whether or not what I think is
funny.
I know,
I know that I know how to make things
funny.
I know,
I know what things are funny and aren't
funny because I do stand up so much.
So it's like you become immersed in the
language of comedy,
but when you're removed from that,
completely removed from the idea or the
act of creating the comedy and then
producing it and putting it on stage and
performing it.
And then honing it and then sharpening
up the bits and,
and you learn things from that like,
oh,
that was way better when I did it this
way because I got to it quicker and the
people understood it better.
You become in the language of company b,
you stay good,
you stay good.
But when they stopped doing comedy,
man,
he stopped writing comedy and they just
sort of like,
just acting in movies for awhile.
Like you just,
you might as well be living on mars
motherfucker.
You're not even living with people.
You're walking around in a plastic
bubble and people are getting used to,
you know,
bagels and lox at the craft service
table and you pull it up in a ferrari
and complaining,
you know,
because there's an up knocking it shit,
and you go into set and you're getting
makeup put on,
you know,
they're fucking fitting a hairpiece to
you to make your hair look big and
thick.
You know what I mean?
That's what it was kind of a weird world
is that you're walking down the carpet
and then that's your interaction with
humans.
Your interaction with humans is on the
set and people serving you and then your
next project and it's always this weird
relationship where you're a star and
their underlings and they all need to
keep you happy to keep their job and so
everyone's like super supportive and you
don't even know what the fuck is up and
what's down.
You just drunk all the time.
It was fucked up on pills,
you know,
you don't even know.
It's the reason why so many of these
guys become completely insane.
You know,
that,
that world,
the idea of living like that,
it's just,
you've got to be out of your fucking
head.
One of the most frustrating things ever
when I first moved to hollywood is just
dealing with actors.
You know,
guys who have done it their whole lives
and guys who had been involved in the
business for decades and she'd be
dealing with them and you aren't even
fucking real.
You know,
you just,
you're so odd and fake and everybody's
fake and everybody accepts that
everyone's fake.
No one's calling anybody out at any of
this and the behavior is so strange.
You know,
everybody's pompous and
she does a lot of extra work and so
she's always on sets with like,
like she was on set the other day with a
was that guy's name the rapper,
ll cool j and stuff like that.
Did you ever have any crazy stories of
working with some of these people?
Because this is funny.
A ll cool j's walking aRound.
I didn't know who it was.
One point at ll cool j.
Nobody looks like I've only heard him.
I never looked at a picture.
What was the other thing that you didn't
know?
That we were talking?
He doesn't know a lot of stuff,
which is kind of cool.
Something yesterday that was really
weird.
Oh,
you didn't know aBout the howard stern
show?
you didn't know who robin was that there
was.
That to me is she doesn't know a lot of
things like,
like you go do you know this tv show?
She's like,
what cosby show?
That doesn't make sense.
I Would think it would be able to do.
Most people would be able to name who
robin quivers was and howard and know
that more people would know that.
Then know who was president before
clinton.
Yeah.
But you know nowadays howard stern,
she's 22.
You,
she,
she missed that big howard stern
willing.
YeaH,
I mean the point.
Okay.
Because he was on satellite radio when
you were like in high school.
Right.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Right.
Wow.
It's still same.
Insane.
Yeah.
So what about.
Okay.
Anyway,
go ahead.
L cool.
J.
So you didn't know who l cool j dot.
I didn't know what ll cool j looked
like,
but someone pointed out to me and he's
going up all on set all around like the
girls and he's like,
hey ladies,
how you do in rubbing their shoulders?
He's like,
hey,
yeah,
you looking good?
What you doing?
I'm looking at him this and I'm like,
this
guy is ridiculous.
He's walking around like he owned the
place touching all these young girls and
they're like,
oh,
and I'm like,
you better not touch me.
I'm like,
please use your ll cool j credit.
Just to be like,
hey ladies.
I just thought it was like kind of a
douchey his thing.
But were you hating because he didn't
come rub on you?
Oh no.
WHat am I.
A cycle with the girls.
Girls not like it.
No,
the girls were into it.
I'm just looking at it.
I'm like,
that's so unreal.
Like he just walking around like if theY
liked it,
what's the problem?
If they liked it and he liked doing it.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's just,
it's odd.
You thought that he was gonna do to you.
That's why it was weird.
No,
it's just weird that he does it because
he's ll cool j because a regular guy
who's not his status wouldn't walk
around like.
Yeah,
right.
But he is ll cool j,
right?
Yeah,
that's what she's saying is weird.
It's just like a normal person.
He's walking up.
Is he using that credit?
If the girls actually like it,
that's where it gets tricky.
If they actually like him doing that,
is he using it or not even saying that?
She's just saying it's weird seeing
somebody act like a planner.
I don't give a shit.
I totally agree with you,
but if they like it,
is it still weird?
Like if,
if I saw that,
it would be weird if I saw some guy
walking around going,
hey,
what's up baby?
It's ooh,
gimme kiss,
but why would we judge this if we,
if he's enjoying it and they're enjoying
it.
You knoW what I'm saying?
It's one thing if you came up to you and
you were like,
okay,
this is fucking.
I just came here to work.
All right.
I don't want to be weirded out by some
cultive personality,
but that'd be me being prissy.
Then that's not you being prissy.
You know,
I just thought it was someone should not
violate your space.
like if,
if you know,
if there was like if you were there or
you know,
you're dating guy and he's right next to
you and your uncle jay did that,
that would be disrespectful,
right?
Yeah,
of course.
Right.
Well that then it's disrespectful.
Even if your boyfriend's not there,
you're not supposed to go up to someone.
Just start touching them.
You know,
you gotta she's gotta know that you,
you know,
you like him first or there's got to be
some communication going,
hey,
can I rub your shoulders?
You can't just go up and start rubbing
people he was doing and he liked it.
I liked it.
Could be guessed that to like the
clinton move and clinton will just pull
his dick out on girls' jail.
Clinton used to do that.
yeah,
dude,
he did it a bunch of times.
They're just hilarious because it's like
a frat boy move.
Like clinton would be alone with chicks
and just pull his dick out and people
go,
how could he do that?
I'll tell you how he could do that
because it works.
It probably worked 80 percent of the
time.
You know,
it probably worked even more than that.
He's fucking bill clinton.
If I bet if he felt of thing,
he felt the green light,
I'm going to go for it.
I bet he whipped out his dick and like
80 percent of the time it was a,
it was a home run,
but it was those,
the awkward 20 that would just,
it would just crash into the woods,
like he misread them or they just got so
offended that he would do that,
that they just flipped over the other
way,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
But he would rock that all the time.
That's what he would do.
And just pull his dick out.
What's your hatred of hot chicks?
But hold on a second.
I'm not finished there.
So that's like what ll cool j is doing.
He's doing a very mild version of
pulling his dick out.
He just going for it.
Yeah,
I guess so.
So if you're with a guy,
right,
and you really attracted the guy and he
pulls dick out his
dick out and you just go for it.
Just be like,
what do you think?
I am like really into them.
If you're really into the guy,
it's possible.
Right.
If you were.
If I was to check into it was a perfect
situation,
the perfect circumstance.
The guy pulls his dick out and got to
go,
what the hell?
I think there's a difference though if
like really liking ll cool j because
he's you a celebrity and liking his rap
and then thinking,
okay,
now he has his dick out.
Wait,
we're not talking about ll cool j.
President is a different story.
We're mixing up our metaphors,
but I think I totally agree with you.
I would think it would be gross too,
but if they like it and he likes it,
then it's a match made in heaven.
Heaven.
Well,
you know,
I mean I bet a lot of girls that come on
the show just to meet him.
You know ll cool j suck symbol,
right?
One of those freaky bitches.
They'd probably come on shore.
They probably act as extras just to be
lol.
I can't believe he right there.
Oh my goodness.
It's probably mostly 40 year old women
own 30 year old woman.
Really young girls going,
oh my god,
ll cool j.
You're crazy.
He's a stud.
He's 22 years old right here.
Built like a linebacker.
You might think like,
girls think that that's sexy,
but I'm like,
I see a 45 year old man who's probably
married.
I don't know,
but he just looks like a man.
Like he looks.
It's not sexy.
Ll cool j is sexy,
very sexy.
He's built.
He's got fucking workout books.
Was on the cover.
Completely shredded.
Hating my own theory is starting to
become correct.
What is the ll cool j theory?
I don't know.
This is the second time we've talked
about ll cool j and then you've defended
his honor.
So I'm thinking,
well,
I probably wouldn't want to hang out
with the dude,
but I do.
I defend his right to be cocky.
Ll cool j pulled it off,
you know,
plus he's a rapper.
Rappers have to be cocky.
That's part of the sport.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's just me.
It's attractive to know a guy it like
physical fitness,
but it's not like hot because they're
like muscular bill.
That's all.
That's all you.
Everybody's different.
Everybody has different guys like fat
chicks,
like a big,
big fat ones.
We have friends.
We have to get this one fan.
He's not happy and the girls just 30,
40 pounds overweight.
He likes it.
He likes some gigli and barely hanging
onto their clothes for whatever reason.
Turns him on and he's a skinny guy to
sustain.
Hmm.
I think it's a smell that they give off
some certain people just like fuck,
like food,
right?
Like pheromones.
Second difference between sweaty butt
and thigh and mixed with old hamburgers
that turns people on.
Yeah.
Maybe it's someone.
I think it is.
Honestly,
I think it's your first sexual
experience.
You know,
you have like a really hot sexual
experience with a fat girl and you beat
your brain becomes imprinted to
sexuality.
Being attract people is kind of
interesting.
That means I would like brown hair,
girls with big boobs,
brown haired girls with big boobs.
That was your first.
Yeah.
Tell us more about you.
Do you get that?
Do you have like a specific type?
No,
I don't.
Not at all.
I'm not crazy.
Pretty much just what I live for
nowadays.
Not crazy and not crazy.
Yeah.
What percentage of girls that you dated
had been crazy?
Most of them.
90?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Do you think girls are crazy,
allison,
you,
you're around a lot of chicks.
Do you think the majority of your
friends are to blame and that they are
like the crazy person.
They'll be like,
oh,
so I have an issue with my boyfriend,
but I think I'm just not going to tell
him and see if it will go away without
me telling them,
but I'm going to act mad and him next
time I see him,
I'm like,
why would you do that?
Here's a question.
When you're around a bunch of people and
you keep having relationships like this
over and over and over again where you
would crazy people,
you have all these problems.
How do you stop that?
How do you reset and how do you somehow
another move forward without all this
bullshit in your life?
How do you do that?
Um,
I try to like most,
most of my crazy ass bitches.
I tried to remain friends with them and
have some kind of cool level with them
where I,
uh,
it makes yourself kind of healed that
way to think,
okay,
this person is fucking crazy back.
It's still be friends with this crazy
bitch,
you know?
Right.
But I'm saying,
how do you move forward in your own life
and stop this from happening.
Stop this pattern from a peanut.
How do I stop data?
crazy bitches become gay.
Obviously starts sucking dick.
Ll cool j looked me up.
Where you at?
Girl?
That was a sad,
sad answer.
I think the answer is you don't have an
answer right now.
No,
I don't.
I really don't have an answer.
I mean,
how do you have an answer for that?
I mean look at allison psycho.
Make eyes over there and she's about to
snap.
look at her.
Are you about to snap some of those,
those,
uh,
uncomfortable moments and the drunk
cast,
especially the first one when you guys
were hanging on each other.
I'm like,
wow,
do you really want this out there?
Man?
Why?
Because you're so silly.
It's just like,
it felt like dirty.
I was like,
oh,
it's like a lawyer lawyer,
but like I was watching two people in a
living room hanging out and they were
drunk and they were being silly
together.
Like I felt like I shouldn't be here.
That's great.
Well,
did you have pants on?
No,
I never have pants on.
That's probably what their main reason
why you shouldn't be watching us walk
around naked,
man,
bro.
I don't want to close friends.
I grew up with.
I've known him since we were like 10.
He says he was watching it and he's
like,
honestly,
I got like kind of uncomfortable feeling
as I was watching it.
Yeah.
a lot of people actually said this,
you know why?
Because he wants to fuck you.
That's what's up.
What I mean dude,
that dude.
Yeah.
He got uncomfortable and nobody got
uncomfortable because it's just.
Some guy was when I was younger and she
don't know.
You don't know me.
I'm just like,
I thought you were gay.
You thought he was gay.
I'd say when we were kids and he has a
girlfriend,
but he does have a thing for you.
Huh?
And he said it once and get the fuck out
of my room.
Oh really?
What happened?
I'm all high and I'm trying to go to bed
and he was living me and he comes
from my elbow.
Here's your roommate?
Yeah,
because his parents got kicked out.
Do you ever find like loads in your
shoes or anything?
Like,
is that what it was?
Know?
He comes in my room and he's like,
hey allison,
sit in my little chair like this next to
my bed and I'm like,
hey,
what's going on?
And he's like,
so been thinking like if we weren't such
good friends I would fuck you.
And I was like,
get tHe fuck out of my room.
Yeah.
and that's it.
We never brought it back up.
I brought it back up like couple of
weeks later and I was like,
you want to fuck me?
And then he's like,
no,
I don't.
Making fun of them saying,
oh,
what a friend.
A confidence booster.
Awesome.
having prejudice and jump out of a
fucking window and I'll never get it.
Well,
you know,
how old was he at the time?
Uh,
we were 19.
You don't know what the last year.
Eighteen months.
Two years ago and many months.
Months.
Two and a half years.
Seventeen hundred days.
Not that much.
Really.
When you think about it,
two and a half years ago,
you were the same guy when you were like
22 though.
It's just fucking world.
If you knew me in 22,
you'd be so scared of me or two and a
half years before that,
right?
Yeah,
we crazy back then.
And I was crazier and I was a hippie
probably just because I was fucked up.
You were talking about earlier we were
talking about,
um,
jersey shore.
Like could you imagine if you had a
video cameras folloWing you around back
when you were at that stage?
You know,
you'd come off.
So douchey.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Gross.
Even when I was 18,
I used to think I was invincible.
I wanted that whole stage where I'm
like,
yeah,
I don't even wear my seatbelt.
All that other bullshit.
You don't want to get a motorcycle.
Yeah.
And then you get out of that stage and
you're like,
what was I doing?
He never been hurt before.
I have,
I got it.
I heard a bunch of times as a kid,
so I never had that feeling.
I broke my arm when I was six.
I snap like snap my forearm and to where
it was like hanging off,
it was fucking creepy and there was like
a big dent in the middle of my forearm
and my hand was like the wrong,
you know,
it was hanging like folded,
traumatizing.
That was really bad.
It was a bad break.
Yeah.
They didn't have to go play tennis
though.
They just set it somehow or another.
You should hear this car accident.
She was in man.
Really fucking want to talk about that?
About her boYfriend and her wearing a
tie.
How old were you?
I waS 15.
Seatbelt or no seat belt and that was in
the back seat.
Got my best friend,
the girl who actually said I wasn't a
woman of god.
She went crazy from this.
What happened real in front of this from
this accident?
Well,
you could have included that when you
were telling us how she was.
No,
it's
good because I can relate it.
So she's sitting on my right or
whatever.
My left,
my boyfriend at the time is on my right.
There's a guy driving and we're going
down the road and we're going to go to a
haunted house.
So he makes like a u turn and winds up
hydroplaning.
And we hit a tree going like 55 miles an
hour.
Oh.
And I wake up covered in blood and
everyone had to pretty much get cut out
of the car.
And my boyfriend was pronounced dead,
but he lived,
but it was in a coma for two months.
They had brain surgery.
All because my cheekbone hit his temple
and it slipped,
severed an artery and his brain got
pushed over to the side and the other
kid was pronounced dead but lived.
But he's like kind of brain damaged.
He's okay now though.
And then uh,
my best friend who obviously was okay
next to me,
but she got a concussion and after that
she was like,
I'm a woman of god.
So I,
yeah,
the next day,
um,
I'm in the hospital and the guy comes in
and he goes,
alice and I want to be here if it wasn't
bad news,
but one of the guys aren't gonna make it
through the night.
And I was like,
oh great.
And it was my boyfriend and I is um,
like 11th month anniversary that day.
So it was like really fucked up.
Then I go to the hospital finally to go
see him and they are reading him his
last rites because they were gonna loan
is oregon's out.
Wow.
But he lived and he was kinda like slow
for awhile,
but now he's totally fine.
He's noT the same person before the
accident,
but he had still a person have your face
on his face.
He has a big scar all the way to here
and all because like my cheekbone was
just like smash god.
Damn.
Yeah,
that was nuts.
But hydroplaning scary as fuck man.
shitty cars.
My first car was a 68,
four,
two,
my wife now,
my first car,
my first car was a [inaudible] 73
chevelle,
but my first car that was worth more
than $10 was a 68,
four,
two and is a old hot rod and it had a
400 cubic inch engine that was like way
too much power for a retard like me,
you know,
and I was like 16,
maybe 17 at the time.
And uh,
I hydroplaned right in front of my
school.
I just,
I had bald tires.
The tires just weren't that good and
there was a lot of water on the ground
and the car slid sideways and slammed
into a fucking telephone pole and a tree
broke the car in half.
Why haven't you?
Nothing.
Nothing was fine.
And the crazy thing is that me and the
two dudes I was driving with,
we're fun.
We didn't,
we weren't going that fast.
It was just a shitty car,
just fucking old,
you know?
And it,
it,
you know,
if you hit the tree like that with a new
car today,
it wouldn't do nearly as much damage.
But that car just broken half.
It was just kind of old and the frame
wasn't good I guess.
But I,
I had a pretty good.
I mean They hit a pretty decent,
but I wasn't even going that fast man.
It was just,
just those old cars,
they just,
you have no control of them.
They suck,
man.
The break sucked.
Oh remember how long it used to take?
Oh my god,
I had a,
a skylark and 1970 skylark.
And you'd,
you'd have to like,
be really careful with the breaks.
You'd have to be really careful with
stopping like stop way earlier than you
think because you're like,
come on,
come on.
Come on.
Like every time you stopped it was an
ordeal.
You know,
you like have a new car today,
man with disc brakes.
Abs and cheerleaders.
yeah.
Technology rather than technology.
Someday they're going to be making fun
of people for driving around thinking
like you remember when people had to
like get in their car and try places.
When people have to wake up and go
outside to teleport,
bro,
you're going to be able to teleport you
to be able to move
like the mailman.
When is that going to go out of business
very soon.
That's fine.
Five years.
I would say.
I still send things,
bought things and get things ordered by
mail and
send.
I have to send checks in and stuff.
It's going to be so upbeat like
unpractical soon.
Well,
the problem is when you have no paper,
you have no fucking.
You know,
it's like things are getting weirder and
weirder.
At one point in time,
money used to represent gold,
right?
it used to represent your $100 bills
worth $100 worth of gold.
well,
it doesn't really mean that anymore.
now it's like it's just,
you just have confidence that this $100
is worth $100.
And what happens if a zoologist numbers
I'll give.
you don't even have paper.
You just look.
You're constantly looking at computer
screens.
Those screens are telling you what your
numbers are and where are these numbers
located?
Are they somewhere,
are they even fucking real?
And then the,
the,
the economy becomes so transparent and
so elusive and then it becomes too
fucking strange.
You know,
I think we need,
we need some physical form,
we need money,
you need paper money.
We still need that shit.
We need something to just cling us to
the idea that that money is a real
thing,
you know,
when it all just becomes zeros and ones
and zeros and then just people just
start jacking each other for the ones
and zeros and adding ones and zeros
where they don't belong and it's
fucking,
it's not good man.
It's like all the shit that's going
down,
all the money that goes to Iraq and
Afghanistan and how much of it's
missing?
Like all that.
The halliburton scams and scandals.
Fucking billions.
Billions of dollars missing.
Yeah.
They don't know where it is.
They'll find it.
Did something.
Then lately,
uh,
the,
the youtube banos organization,
red,
do you know about all this?
It's supposed to be for aids in africa
or 66 percent of the money stolen.
They don't know where the fucking wet
people were stealing from banos and a
helping aids organization.
People just suck
jesus dealings going on over there or
around here.
Question.
I don't think they've isolated it yet.
Could have easily been going on in
africa.
I mean,
how can you put it past africa,
right?
one for you.
One for me.
A documentary of iberia.
How they had to get out of their cars.
Like they heard that the guys had money.
So the guys who were filming it had to
get out.
When you're talking about the vice guide
to Liberia,
we talk about that on the podcast almost
every week because it's so fucking
crazy.
If you havE not seen it,
folks,
please get it.
You said it's on netflix,
right?
Netflix.
Streaming.
Yeah.
Um,
how did we get into this conversation?
We're talking about project red.
Oh,
the,
the scam.
you know,
the,
the billions of dollars missing this
youtube guy.
Banos fucking organization.
And then the halliburton shit.
How much money is missing there?
If halliburton was like one guy,
they would never be able to get away
with that,
you know,
it was one person.
it's like,
where's your missing billions?
Where is it?
Oh no,
it's gone.
But becAuse of the corporation,
you know,
it's like you could,
you could be missing billions,
but the weIrd thing is they get to vote
like a person,
like in these,
they get to use money like a person and
make donations like a person,
like one of the most recent,
one of the most recent findings or
supreme court rulings was that
corporations have the same rights as an
individual so they could donate money.
An individual can donate like whatever
you want,
which is ridiculous.
So Vermont is a,
the first state to step up and deny that
Vermont is the first date and the
recently announced that they are not
going to allow corporations to behave as
a,
as a human being and that they're going
to judge them in a different way.
so it's kind of interesting.
You know,
It's interesting that one state finally
has the balls to step up.
You know,
Vermont has a weird state.
It's always been like real kind of
hippie,
you know,
kinda like ben and jerry's grateful dead
fish and it's not that many people up
there,
you know?
Isn't that the way that bob dole,
god came from?
Not bob dole.
The other guy.
I'm the guy that got.
He was running for president and carry.
No,
no,
no.
The guy was running for president and
then he screamed too much and they a
fucking cunt.
You don't know his name
trying to search.
I'm like searching my brain.
Nothing.
Uh,
I don't remember his name.
God dammit.
He was a really articulate guy.
I'm sure someone on twitter will tell me
almost immediately he was a really
articulate guy.
But uh,
for whatever reason he did this one
speech where a while he was doing a
speech fucking homeboy started yelling
just to like,
was just like,
he excited.
Then we're gonna,
you know,
then we're going to take over New York
and I'm going to take over.
And it was like at a rally and he didn't
realize,
you know,
that the microphone,
when you think you're screaming and
yelling,
you know,
and you think that the sound of the
crowd is like a,
you're at the same level of this out of
the crowd.
So you can't even hear your own voIce.
Well the microphone right in front of
his face.
So the microphone is only picking him up
so it sounded like extra.
Completely crazy.
Alright.
Someone will tell me on the message
board please,
because I know you fuckers know whose
name is 66 percent of banos money.
Howard dean.
Thank you sir.
Mr.
Dennis.
And he came up with it.
That's the dude's name.
Howard dean.
I believe he was the um,
the governor of Vermont.
So it's a,
it's a freaky little fucking state.
But they stepped up and said the
corporations aren't people you fuck
heads.
Will that help?
No,
not unless you moved to Vermont.
Do want to move to Vermont?
No,
it's too cold.
Vermont now my friend shane lived at
night and there was points where it was
snowing so bad that he had to like drive
through tunnels.
just,
you know,
like they had done.
he was stuck at his house for weeks at
times.
Oh yeah.
That's normal.
Fuck that.
vermont's no joke.
You can't be traveling on the road as
much as we do in live with romana.
So that's out.
There was one other thing that I want to
talk about before we get out of here,
but I don't remember what it is.
Um,
got anything brian?
yeah.
And she goes here.
Yeah.
I think I already told you.
But flavor flave has a new chicken.
He selling chicken now and uh,
it's hilarious.
It's got flavor.
Flavor's fried chicken and it's in I
believe Iowa.
And if you to google it,
google is search that and just look at
the advertising for it to this one.
It doesn't even look like flavor flavor,
flavor.
Flavor is fried chicken mixed with
chicken wings.
There's a lot people love chicken and
Iowa.
Hilarious stuff.
Flavor flavor is one of those dudes just
always going to kind of be around.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah,
mean you don't hear about chuck d
anymore?
You never hear about professor griff.
You don't hear about other members?
Yeah.
You know terminator x,
terminator x bro.
I don't know.
But fLavor flave.
Did you watch the flavor flavor show
were uh,
they were trying to get them a
girlfriend and the one girl who shit on
the stairs.
Yes.
That was so fucking.
I see that.
I didn't say that.
But brian,
her what happened?
She passed out and she showed it on the
stairs or something like that.
Something like that.
Another she shit and it wound up on
stairs or she.
Yeah.
fuck was that.
I think she was walking up the stairs
and shit.
Her pants fell out on thIs.
Did he keep her on the show?
Oh,
I don't know.
But I mean come on.
What?
What kind of human is just shitting
themselves around dropping logs out of
their parents.
I want to wish.
Hope that's completely real to stone
director.
Like,
dude,
just put a little poop coming out.
He had all the girls make chicken and
see what make the best chicken and then
he this one lady surgeon and he's like,
are you serious?
Is this an even copd?
I can't believe you'd serve those.
Can you fucked it up?
well,
that's unfortunate.
Kicked her off.
Some people aren't that good at making
chicken.
The reality shows don't have to make
things up,
man.
Those shows,
they don't have to.
You know,
shows like jersey shore.
You don't have to.
There's enough craziness out there.
Teen moms,
they don't have to.
You don't have to make something though.
That's like I auditioned for that ww ii
divas thing and then I didn't really
know what it was all about and she tells
me I did.
When was this last week in the house?
She was like,
oh,
it's a show.
Yeah,
I guess like you get in the house and
then you do all these competitive type
things where you battle for like a wwe
diva where you do like interviews and
fights sometimes.
The girl was like,
you're almost perfect for this spot,
dah,
dah.
And I was like,
sweet.
And then I was thinking about it and I'm
like,
oh,
it's going to be six weeks of filming
and they're gonna.
It's gonna be crazy.
Reality show.
Probably if it did work out.
Alright.
so what does that mean?
I would never want to be in a house for
six weeks.
I would never do those reality show.
But when you're 22,
I liked taking opportunities that sound
like kind of crazy.
so I actually would probably.
So you're going to do it even be a pro
wrestler.
You know what?
Some day when you're a big name pro
wrestling,
you're on tv and you're battling will
say we called it here first when you're
like a,
like an interviewer and then you get
drawn into the fight,
right?
That's what's going to happen.
Right?
So if they want.
Yeah,
I think it's a good move.
I would say do it.
I think it sounds fun.
Flicks here.
My neck.
You know your,
your,
how you can flex your time.
You will be able to see on the shirt.
Well you flex your boobs.
Pec muscles.
Oh,
okay.
That's creepy.
She just raises each one.
But she's getting you to work out with
you guys were hanging out.
You're going to get a gym pass.
I can physically train you.
She's a physical training.
Powerful alpha male.
Female.
Well,
no I wouldn't.
We could just run together.
No,
no,
not into it.
No.
You don't care about shape shit.
You're happy with your shape.
Fuck you're happy with your cigarettes
and everything.
You don't need to change.
Change.
Don't change
west.
Probably just weekend.
You dirty dirty bitches.
Thanks to the flashlight for sponsoring
the show.
If you go to joe rogan.net,
again,
click the link type in rogan.
It's all explained for you.
Get 15 percent off a thank you allison.
If you guys want to follow allison on
twitter,
it's allison rocks.
R o x and there's two l's and allison.
I didn't know that.
Thanks so much for having a michelle.
Thanks for being honest.
And a red band is red,
b a n and you probably know mine is
just.
My name was.
Fuck,
are you?
I dunno,
I dunno.
I don't think you know who you are
either.
I think you're fronting.
ALl right.
We will be back.
I'm most likely tomorrow.
I always say that and sometimes we don't
have a show,
but I think we're going to put one
together tomorrow.
you motherfuckers.
All right,
so this weekend I'm a west palm beach
improv 28th,
29th and 30th with ari shaffir next
weekend.
The big fat fucked up show in vegas.
Friday,
February 4th,
mandalay bay theater.
Jody as ari shaffir inmates.
A big fucking place,
but tickets are selling fast.
So if you want to get their shred phone,
go online to joe rogan.ne.
There's a link for that too.
All right,
love you guys.
See you soon.
bye.